Hey guys, welcome to my cold open and it's a real cold open because I have a cold and this is the open of the show that we call smartness. Let's go. Wait JB, let's talk about this. Sometimes I get more excited about Jason's life than Jason does. And I'm so excited about carry on with Taryn Edgerton, which you just wrapped filming. So I'm super, super, super excited about that. Well, me too. I was excited because Jason last week, no, no, this is not hurtful, was about to shoot a scene where he, I don't want to wreck the ending, but I know the story. This is funny, but you know the end. And I was so happy to hear what he had to do.
嘿大家，欢迎来到我的冷开场，这真的是个冷开场，因为我感冒了，这就是我们称之为“聪明”的节目开场。开始吧。等等，JB，我们来聊聊这个。有时候我对杰森的生活比他自己还兴奋。我对泰伦·埃格顿主演的《携带》感到非常兴奋，你刚拍完那部戏。所以我超级超级超级兴奋。我也是。我之所以兴奋是因为杰森上周，不，不，这没什么恶意，他当时要拍一场戏，他……我不想剧透结局，但我知道故事。这很有趣，但你知道结局。听到他必须要做的事情，我真的很高兴。
That is really funny. Can you say, Jay? I had to, I had to perform an extremely dramatic scene, right? The most dramatic thing you could ever do. And you know, it's just, it's the kind of thing you never want to have to act out. And I, and I had to, and I think I averted or I avoided the larger minds in the minefield. But I did smell my sad card burning in my back pocket just a little bit. I don't know if it burned all the way through, but can you tell the, can you tell the thing, how you reblocked the fight choreography? Oh yeah. Well, there's a minimum I'm supposed to have this big fight with Taryn. And, and of course we go in there and the stunt coordinators are, you know, are always amazing and they
那真的很有趣。你能说吗，杰伊？我不得不，我不得不表演一场极其戏剧化的戏，对吧？你能做的最戏剧化的事情。你知道，这正是那种你永远不想去演的事情。我，我不得不演，我想我避开了雷区里最大的地雷。但我确实闻到我后口袋里的“悲伤卡”烧焦了一点点。我不知道它是否完全烧穿了，但你能告诉大家，你能告诉大家你是如何重新编排打斗动作的吗？哦，是的。嗯，本来我应该和泰伦有一场大打斗。当然，我们进去的时候，特技协调员总是很棒，他们
always come up with great stunts. But inevitably, if you're a, if you're a soft sort of, you know, 54 year old guy like me, only swings hammers when there's a large insect around. You're going to say, no, thanks. I don't want to do the real intense stunt stuff. Can we, can we reimagine this fight to where I just get him in an immediate chokehold and we just have, we do our two pages of dialogue with both of us on our backs and I've got him sort of, you know, neutralized. And there was supposed to be like, like 25 karate chop moves. And like, cause I'm supposed to be a very skilled bad guy that knows how to really get you just one headlock and done. I'm like, yeah, I feel like my character is kind of bored
总是能想出很棒的特技。但不可避免地，如果你像我一样是个54岁的软弱家伙，只有在周围有大昆虫时才会挥动锤子。你会说，不，谢谢。我不想做那种真正激烈的特技动作。我们能不能，我们能不能重新构思这场打斗，让我直接把他锁喉，然后我们背靠背念完两页台词，我就这样，你知道，把他制服了。本来应该有大约25个空手道劈砍动作。因为我应该是一个非常熟练的坏蛋，知道如何一招锁喉就搞定。我说，是的，我觉得我的角色现在对那些东西有点厌倦了。
with all that stuff now. My character would be in slippers at home by now. I feel like my character would go out for dinner once a month. It makes me feel a little bit more of a podcaster, by the way, by the way, Amanda kept going, you know, this era is after, but Amanda kept going, and he's coming back next week and then he's done with the movie and he's going to go and you guys get to go to pebble beach and then done and then golf is done. And then I'm done with it. We've got the genesis, we've got the genesis pro am a week after that. I thought we were doing the pro am. I thought it was pro am because it took place in the
我的角色现在应该在家里穿着拖鞋了。我觉得我的角色一个月会出去吃一次晚餐。顺便说一句，这让我感觉更像个播客了。顺便说一句，阿曼达一直说，你知道，这个时代之后，但阿曼达一直说，他下周回来，然后电影就拍完了，他要去圆石滩，然后就结束了，高尔夫也就结束了。然后我就完成了。我们一周后还有捷恩斯公开赛。我以为我们在做职业业余配对赛。我以为是职业业余配对赛，因为它发生在
morning, right? Like, is there a pro PM? I'm dead serious. That's what I was fired off of this. What's am? Why is it am? Professionally amateur pro am. Is that what you? Oh my gosh. There it is. Oh my God, I hear our guests live. I don't mean to. I hear our guests live. Let's get right to it. While we're talking about actors, let's go ahead and get to this guy. So sometimes an actor has talent and then sometimes they have good looks and then sometimes they got both. Our next guest has got neither. No real bone structure to speak of. He's got not much of a speaking voice. His talent has been questioned by some of the greats after working with him. Folks like De Niro, Pitt, Blanchette, Christian
早上，对吧？就像，有职业下午配对赛吗？我是认真的。这就是我被解雇的原因。什么是AM？为什么是AM？职业业余配对赛（Pro-Am）。你是这个意思吗？天哪。原来如此。天哪，我听到我们的嘉宾上线了。我不是故意的。我听到我们的嘉宾上线了。我们直接进入正题吧。既然我们在谈论演员，让我们直接请出这位。有时候演员有天赋，有时候他们长得好看，有时候两者兼备。我们的下一位嘉宾两者都没有。没啥骨相可言。说话声音也没什么特色。他的天赋在与他合作过的一些大人物之后受到质疑。像德尼罗、皮特、布兰切特、克里斯蒂安·
Bale, Albert Finney, Tom Cruise, Matt Damon, directors Woody Allen, Cameron Crow, Tom Stoppard. They all worked with him just the once. Wow. Wow. Award givers have been equally circumspect, giving him one Tony Award, not 10, not 12. He's received one Emmy. Again, not 10, not 12. He's not a rookie, but at 54, he's only been doing this for 30 years. And finally, he could be a bit brighter, having received not a PhD, just a master's. So let's try to lift his spirits up. Let's get the word out there for this guy, because while he may have a bunch of fancy credits out there, he may need some work because he's starring in only two television series at the current time. Let's give a warm welcome, a supporting
贝尔、阿尔伯特·芬尼、汤姆·克鲁斯、马特·达蒙，导演伍迪·艾伦、卡梅伦·克罗、汤姆·斯托帕德。他们都只和他合作过一次。哇。哇。奖项评委也同样谨慎，只给了他一个托尼奖，不是10个，不是12个。他只获得过一个艾美奖。同样，不是10个，不是12个。他不是新手，但在54岁时，他只干了30年。最后，他本可以更聪明一点，因为他没拿到博士学位，只拿到了硕士学位。所以让我们试着提振一下他的精神。让我们为这家伙宣传一下，因为虽然他可能有很多华丽的履历，但他可能需要一些工作，因为他目前只主演了两部电视剧。让我们热烈欢迎，支持性地
welcome to Thomas and George Ann's boy, Billy Crudup. Oh, my gosh. Bravo. Bravo. It's our dinner, pal. Hi, guys. Wow. That's an awful lot not to live up to. Well, right? So that was sort of complimentary yet kind of hurtful at the same time, right? It was the kind of greeting I would expect from a close, close friend who doesn't ever have to call. Yeah, we've never met. We're meeting right now. Don't weigh in on this. Don't weigh in. It's the kind of friendship. I text you regularly for me. It's important to keep boundaries. I'm pleased that Will is so skilled at exercising that talent in his relationship. He's not. Will's worse
欢迎托马斯和乔治·安的儿子，比利·克鲁德普。天哪。太棒了。太棒了。这是我们的晚餐伙伴。嗨，伙计们。哇。这评价高得让人难以承受。嗯，对吧？所以这既是恭维，又有点伤人，对吧？这是我从一个永远不需要打电话的亲密朋友那里期待的问候。是的，我们从未见过面。我们现在正在见面。别插嘴。别插嘴。这就是那种友谊。我经常给你发短信。对我来说，保持界限很重要。我很高兴威尔在处理这种关系时如此擅长运用这种天赋。他并不擅长。威尔比我
than me. First of all, not true. Actually, no, of all of us, you're the worst. I want to look up our chain, Will. It's true. Will is pretty good at that. Sean, you and Will are actually pretty good at keeping, you guys text and call. You guys FaceTime all the time, right? Yeah. Kids. You guys FaceTime? I'm not just a phone call. First of all, wipe that shit, that face, look off your face. You FaceTimed me the other night out of the blue from New Orleans because you remember me. Well, because I know that's how you like to do it, like the kids. And you said, wait, and then I FaceTimed right after you did. And Jason, he just told me you made fun of him for the same reason
还差。首先，这不是真的。其实，不，在我们所有人中，你是最差的。我想查查我们的链条，威尔。这是真的。威尔在这方面相当不错。肖恩，你和威尔其实很擅长保持联系，你们会发短信和打电话。你们经常视频通话，对吧？是的。孩子们。你们视频通话？不仅仅是电话。首先，把你脸上那种表情擦掉。你前几天晚上突然从新奥尔良给我视频通话，因为你记得我。嗯，因为我知道你喜欢那样做，就像孩子们一样。你说，等等，然后你打完之后我马上就视频通话了。杰森，他刚才告诉我你因为同样的原因取笑他。
I made fun of him because he was covering his furniture outside when it wasn't raining. Yeah. What's the matter with you, Will? Hey, Billy, Will's got. Why are you covering your furniture when it's not raining? He covers his outdoor furniture with a plastic. I was worried about misting and stuff and I was just, I don't know. Misting? You're worried about misting? But they're outside. I just don't like to get wet. My grandparents used to have plastic on their furniture and we used to come up with the metaphor when you're going to take the plastic off for like living your life. So you don't have to like keep all the furniture covered all the time. It's just kind of like, because it's outdoor furniture.
我取笑他是因为他在没下雨的时候给他的家具盖上遮盖物。是的。威尔，你怎么了？嘿，比利，威尔有。为什么在没下雨的时候你要盖住你的家具？他用塑料布盖住他的户外家具。我担心会有雾气之类的，我只是，我不知道。雾气？你担心雾气？但它们在外面。我只是不喜欢弄湿。我祖父母过去常在家具上放塑料布，我们过去常想出一个比喻，当你打算把塑料布拿掉时，就像是在过你的生活。所以你不必一直把所有家具都盖住。这只是因为它是户外家具。
It's made to be outdoor. So it can be. Well, as everybody knows, we've had the rain out here has been biblical in the last. Yeah, everybody. Yeah. So everybody's been probably we're kind of past that. Yeah, whatever. Anyway, we have Billy, Billy, we don't want to waste Billy. Here's Billy, the great Billy crew. Guys, poolside furniture is my special. I'm hoping that is poolside and not just an outdoor deck or such. He does have a pool over there. A real nice pool. Hey, Bill, I'm just taking a look at your studio apartment. How's everything going? Are you okay? Hey, he's out here on location. I try to keep the cost of living low so I can keep the R high. He's working two shows out here. He
它本来就是为了在户外使用的。所以它可以。嗯，正如大家所知，我们这里的雨在过去一直像圣经里描述的那样大。是的，每个人。是的。所以每个人可能我们已经度过了那个阶段。是的，随便吧。总之，我们有比利，比利，我们不想浪费比利。这是比利，伟大的比利·克鲁德普。伙计们，泳池边的家具是我的专长。我希望那是泳池边，而不仅仅是一个户外露台之类的。他那边确实有一个游泳池。一个非常好的游泳池。嘿，比尔，我只是看了一眼你的单身公寓。一切都好吗？你还好吗？嘿，他是在外景地。我尽量保持生活成本低，这样我才能保持高租金。他在这里拍两部剧。他
lives in the New York City. I know he does. Wait, what's the other show? We know you're on the morning show. What's the other show? It's Hello Tomorrow. Oh, yes. Yeah. Now guess, I want you both to guess what it's about. Will, you first. Hello tomorrow. Time travel. Wow. Good. Time travel. What do you got? You got a Wi-Fi signal over there or something? What about you, Sean? Hello tomorrow. Hello tomorrow. Exclamation point. It's like a romantic story like you're going to tell your girlfriend, hello tomorrow because you can't wait to see her all the time. I don't know what it is. Will's got it. Will's got it. So beautiful musical that we're going to start in together for the first time. Finally making appearance
住在纽约市。我知道他住那。等等，另一部剧是什么？我们知道你在拍《早间新闻》。另一部剧是什么？是《明天，你好》。哦，是的。是的。现在猜猜，我希望你们俩猜猜它是关于什么的。威尔，你先来。《明天，你好》。时间旅行。哇。好。时间旅行。你有什么？你那边有Wi-Fi信号还是什么的？你呢，肖恩？《明天，你好》。《明天，你好》。感叹号。这就像一个浪漫的故事，就像你要告诉你的女朋友，明天你好，因为你一直迫不及待地想见到她。我不知道那是什么。威尔猜对了。威尔猜对了。如此美丽的音乐剧，我们将第一次一起出演。终于露面了
on stage. That's right. Billy, I'm hearing this is about lunar timeshare. What? This is correct. So Will was in the ballpark there. It takes place in a sort of imagined future for America where door-to-door salesmen still exist and we're selling timeshares on the moon. Because travel up there is common. Yeah. It's like the future is going to hold all of the incredible promises that we've all been waiting for, the hover cars, the jetpacks, the timeshares on the moon. It's all going to happen and life will be so much better. When does it come out? February 17th. February 17th. I'm so watching this show. Wait a second. Holy shit, Billy. You kind
在舞台上。没错。比利，我听说这是关于月球分时度假的。什么？这是正确的。所以威尔猜对了。它发生在一个为美国想象的未来，那里仍然有上门推销员，我们正在月球上出售分时度假房。因为去那里的旅行很普遍。是的。就像未来将拥有我们一直在等待的所有不可思议的承诺，悬浮汽车、喷气背包、月球上的分时度假房。这一切都会发生，生活会变得好得多。它什么时候出来？2月17日。2月17日。我一定要看这部剧。等一下。天哪，比利。你有点
of made this on the slide. You didn't tell any of us. I didn't know you were doing this. It's on our chain, Will. I told you all about it. No, it's not. I'm going to go and look back on the chain. You thought he was being rude about now. I'll say hello to you tomorrow. Tomorrow exclamation point. Really sticking the dagger in there. I can see the misunderstanding. Classic crude up. This is on the apple, right? It's on the apple. What kind of place would you be offering timeshares in up there on the moon? Are they condos? Are they like ranches? You can take your pick. We've got A through D units. The A units have poolside three
偷偷摸摸地做了这件事。你没告诉我们任何人。我不知道你在做这个。它在我们的链条上，威尔。我告诉过你们所有人了。不，没有。我要回去看看那个链条。你以为他刚才很粗鲁。我会明天向你问好。《明天，你好》感叹号。真的把匕首插进去了。我能理解这个误解。经典的克鲁德普。这是在苹果上，对吧？是在苹果上。你在月球上会提供什么样的分时度假房？是公寓吗？还是像牧场？你可以选择。我们有A到D单元。A单元有泳池边三
bedrooms, expansive master, overlooking a lunar crater. You have pools up there on the moon. That's correct. Really? This is what we're selling, Jason. The bright side is a corporation that was started to make affordable housing, luxury, but affordable housing for people on the moon so that all of their dreams will come true when they rid themselves of the cesspool that is earth. Let me tell you something. Bateman, if this were real, we all know, the three of us know, that Jason would be the first person. He'd love to go live on the moon and he doesn't have to talk to anybody.
卧室，宽敞的主卧，俯瞰月球陨石坑。你们在月球上有游泳池？没错。真的吗？这就是我们要卖的东西，杰森。光明面是一家为了制造经济适用房而成立的公司，是豪华但经济适用的住房，为了让人们在月球上生活，这样当他们摆脱地球这个污水坑时，他们所有的梦想都会成真。让我告诉你一件事。贝特曼，如果这是真的，我们都知道，我们三个人都知道，杰森会是第一个人。他会喜欢去月球生活，而且他不必和任何人说话。
Imagine how far you drive the ball in almost zero gravity. I'd get such carry from my wedges. Three and a half mile drive. So Billy, there's so many things that I want to get into, but the first thing I want to get into is, tell us a little bit about how Billy started. I mean, I don't even know how you know this. I don't know this story. What was your first introduction to acting? I've got, that's my first question. I don't know Billy's story in that way. What got you started? I know. Hey, Bill. Guys, I have been waiting to tell you my story. How long is this podcast?
想象一下你在几乎零重力的情况下能把球打多远。我的挖起杆会有多大的携带距离。三英里半的开球。所以比利，有很多事情我想深入了解，但第一件事我想深入了解的是，告诉我们一点关于比利是如何开始的。我的意思是，我甚至不知道你是怎么知道这个的。我不知道这个故事。你第一次接触表演是什么时候？我有，这是我的第一个问题。我不知道比利那样的故事。是什么让你开始的？我知道。嘿，比尔。伙计们，我一直在等告诉你们我的故事。这个播客有多长？
We're going to make it a double. For you, you're a friend of the program. So parents were one, what dad was an attorney, maybe dad, dad was not, not an attorney. That was a salesman. He was a traveling salesman. My grandfather was an attorney. So there, there was an attorney in the family. I didn't know a congressman that was previous to that. Yeah. That was several generations ago, both the state senator and the congressman. But that's going back into the 19th and 18th century. There's pedigree. But I wasn't, well, there was a Baptist preacher. And in the article that my grandfather kept, that was, I guess, I guess an homage to him
我们要把它做成双倍长度。对你来说，你是节目的朋友。所以父母是，爸爸是律师，也许爸爸，爸爸不是，不是律师。那是推销员。他是个旅行推销员。我祖父是律师。所以，家里确实有一位律师。我不知道之前还有一位国会议员。是的。那是几代人之前的事了，既是州参议员又是国会议员。但那是追溯到19世纪和18世纪了。有血统。但我不是，嗯，有一位浸信会牧师。在我祖父保留的那篇文章里，我想，我想是对他的致敬
or an obituary. I couldn't tell which in it, but it was told that there was no man of greater pulpit power. So there's a kind of performative streak in the crude up veins there. Yeah. But my dad was not an actor. My mom was not an actor. So all that performing that I did, just as a way to fit in guys, I'm sure you're familiar with that feeling a little bit lonely, a little bit on the outside. There was school in Florida. Yes. There was high school in Florida. Yeah. I went to about eight different schools before I finished high school because we moved around quite a bit. And so my way of fitting in was being the class clown. I was not prodigious
或者是讣告。我分不清是哪一个，但里面说没有比他更有讲坛力量的人了。所以克鲁德普的血管里有一种表演的天赋。是的。但我爸爸不是演员。我妈妈不是演员。所以我做的所有表演，只是为了融入大家，我相信你们对那种感觉很熟悉，有点孤独，有点像局外人。佛罗里达有学校。是的。佛罗里达有高中。是的。我在高中毕业前大约换了八所不同的学校，因为我们搬家搬得相当多。所以我融入的方式就是做班级小丑。我并不出众
in height. So getting the attention of anybody around me required you to throw your voice quite a bit higher. So did you travel, but traveling from school to school and always moving homes and stuff like that? How did that affect you? Like, because Scotty had to do that. Scotty moved like 17 times in his life. So he's always, so whenever he sees moving boxes, he gets stressed out. That was more law motivated though, right? Is that true? Getting on the limb is a little different. There was some proximity. My dad, like he's skirted the edges as well. So there was some anxiety surrounding it. But truthfully, adaptability
在身高方面。所以要引起周围任何人的注意，需要你把声音提高很多。所以你旅行，但从学校到学校，总是搬家之类的？这对你有什么影响？因为斯科蒂必须那样做。斯科蒂一生搬了17次家。所以他总是，所以每当他看到搬家箱，他就会感到压力。那更多是法律驱动的，对吧？那是真的吗？走钢丝有点不同。有一些接近。我爸爸，就像他也游走在边缘。所以周围有一些焦虑。但老实说，适应能力
is what you begin to really rely upon and listening to people, reading people, figuring out what different, what the new group that you want to be friends with and in that grammar school is into. Who they need you to be. Who do they need exactly? So that kind of accommodation works terrific in telling a story. Who do you need me to be in this story? Did you see a movie or TV show or a play that was like, oh, that, that looks really fun. I, I bet I could. Colligula. Yes.
是你开始真正依赖的东西，倾听人们，阅读人们，弄清楚不同的，你想要结交的新群体和在那个小学里喜欢什么。他们需要你成为谁。他们到底需要谁？所以那种适应在讲故事方面非常有效。在这个故事里你需要我成为谁？你有没有看过一部电影或电视节目或戏剧，觉得，哦，那个，看起来真的很有趣。我打赌我也能。卡里古拉。是的。
Wow. Really? Colligula. Wow. It's a thing that really got me going. Wait. So you moved, so you moved around a lot and then did you what, you became all of a sudden you decided you're at, you're a teenager and you sort of getting into theater and doing.
哇。真的吗？卡里古拉。哇。那是真正让我开始的东西。等等。所以你搬家，所以你搬了很多次，然后你做了什么，你突然决定你是，你是个青少年，你开始进入戏剧并做。
Any, any performance that would come up will in school. For instance, if they, if you had to do a presentation for history where they required you to dress up as somebody, I always went a little too far. I always was more comfortable than other people at memorizing the lines and pretending to be. But I went full bore and it was clear that I didn't have any shame. There was no problem being up in front of people and worried that they were going to laugh at me. You should have become a politician. Yeah. Well, having no shame must have really prepared you for the, the, the time that we
任何，任何在学校里出现的表演，威尔。例如，如果你必须为历史课做一个演讲，他们要求你打扮成某个人，我总是做得有点过火。我总是比其他人更舒服地背诵台词并假装是那个人。但我全力以赴，很明显我没有任何羞耻感。站在人们面前并没有问题，也不担心他们会嘲笑我。你应该成为一名政治家。是的。嗯，没有羞耻感一定让你为我们现在
live in now, which is just all it takes is having no shame. Bill, you, you just mentioned memorizing all the lines. I will say something. Okay. Having gone over to having gone over and, and having a little fun with the folks, the gang over there at the morning show the last couple of years. Hold for a plus. Oh yeah, baby. I was a big fan of the show before you being Doug. I love it when Billy calls me Doug,
生活的时代做好了准备，这只需要没有羞耻感。比尔，你，你刚才提到背诵所有的台词。我会说一件事。好吧。过去几年在《早间新闻》和那里的伙计们一起玩得很开心。保持加号。哦，是的，宝贝。在你成为道格之前，我是该节目的忠实粉丝。我喜欢比利叫我道格，
which is just, That was a character. God, you're such a Doug. I know. Doug. I'd like to, Billy and I had like two scenes together and he just kept calling me Doug and Billy's got it. Yeah, but I got to refer to you in a lot of scenes you were there and every time I did
这只是，那是一个角色。天哪，你真是个道格。我知道。道格。我想，比利和我一起演了两场戏，他一直叫我道格，比利猜对了。是的，但我必须在很多场景中提到你，你在那里，每次我这样做
I would go, you got to make sure you get rid of Doug. It was really fun to lean into my idea. That's rich coming from a Corey. He really digs. I know it is rich coming from Corey, but, but he would, but here's the thing, your character on that show, you're so good on that show and you were well deserved and winning, winning the Emmy for it. You have your dialogue. You don't just have dialogue. You have monologues virtually every time you speak and the amount of dialogue you had to memorize for every episode goes
我都会说，你一定要确保摆脱道格。倾听我的想法真的很有趣。这话从一个科里嘴里说出来真是太丰富了。我知道从科里嘴里说出来很丰富，但是，但是事情是这样的，你在那个节目里的角色，你在那个节目里表现得太好了，你赢得艾美奖是当之无愧的。你有你的台词。你不仅仅有台词。你几乎每次说话都有独白，而且你为每一集必须背诵的台词量
above and beyond normally what people have to for TV programs. It's fucking insane. It is. It is crazy. Yeah, it's a lot. How do you do it? It's definitely a lot. There are choices in, because I, I, I, and it was born out of desperation, another quality
超出了通常人们为电视节目所做的。这他妈太疯狂了。确实。确实很疯狂。是的，很多。你是怎么做到的？这绝对很多。有选择，因为我，我，我，这是出于绝望，另一种品质
I think a lot of actors share. And I really wanted this part. I thought it was a fantastic part. I had, I had to convince a few people that I knew how to play in a way that, that would help the show. And part of my pitch was that his mind is extremely facile and he can come up with big ideas and express them over the course of a single breath. So as long as you give me enough time to, I need, you know, a week, two weeks at best to parse one of those out. But you just, there's these things called mnemonics that you can use to try to memorize
我想很多演员都有。我真的很想要这个角色。我觉得这是一个很棒的角色。我不得不说服一些人，我知道如何以一种能帮助节目的方式表演。我推销的一部分是他的思维极其敏捷，他能想出宏大的想法，并在一次呼吸中表达出来。所以只要你给我足够的时间，我需要，你知道，最好是一两周来解析其中一个。但你只是，有这些叫做助记符的东西，你可以用来尝试记忆
dialogue. You know, I think everybody who's an actor, I can guarantee never had a problem memorizing anything. Their brains are built to internalize dialogue as they get older and that facility starts to evaporate. That's when you see people start to get panic attacks, because the one thing that they took for granted that everybody gets, everybody's afraid of public speaking because they're worried they'll forget what they're going to say. People who are actors, they have a brain that can accommodate internalizing text in the same
台词。你知道，我想每个演员，我可以保证从来没有在记忆任何东西方面遇到过问题。他们的大脑天生就能在变老时内化台词，那种能力开始蒸发。那就是你看到人们开始恐慌发作的时候，因为他们认为理所当然的一件事，每个人都得到的，每个人都害怕公开演讲，因为他们担心会忘记要说什么。作为演员的人，他们有一个大脑，可以适应内化文本，就像
way that people who are good at math do. So that's one of the things that is not a problem for me. However, speaking that fast and having thoughts that expansive is extremely difficult as Jason noted in his introduction. I am not, um, not bright, right? Sorry. We're sorry. Were you going to say that? I was going to say, right.
擅长数学的人一样。所以这不是我的问题。然而，说话那么快，有那么广阔的思想是非常困难的，正如杰森在介绍中指出的那样。我不是，嗯，不聪明，对吧？抱歉。我们很抱歉。你是要说那个吗？我要说，对。
I'll cut you off. I was going to, I was going to use a different word, smart, but bright. Yeah. No, I used the word. I used the word. Yeah. Definitely. Because more on point.
我打断你。我本来要，我本来要用一个不同的词，聪明，但明亮。是的。不，我用了那个词。我用了那个词。是的。绝对。因为更切题。
That has, I'm not that, right, bright. So what I do though, is I work. Yeah. Yeah. No one's going to outwork him. I apply pressure through work. Exactly. And you can't talk to Billy before the scene because he's just like got so much shit that
那有，我不是那个，对，明亮。所以我做的是，我工作。是的。是的。没有人会比他更努力。我通过工作施加压力。没错。而且你不能在场景前和比利说话，因为他就像有那么多该死的东西
he's got to say. I do. I sit in the corner. I stare at the corner. And he'll kind of like you, you walk in, you're like, Hey, man, he's like, Hey, just, and you're like, Oh, fuck. He's got this. His energy is like a fucking corner corner.
他必须说。我做。我坐在角落里。我盯着角落。然后你会有点像你，你走进来，你说，嘿，伙计，他说，嘿，只是，然后你说，哦，操。他有这个。他的能量就像一个该死的角落角落。
Are you saying that my ability to learn lines is going to leave me one of these days? I'm just going to say it. It's all I've got. One of the all time greats. Yeah. I'm telling you, Jason can look at a page and you're saying that that's because once that's gone. I'm screwed.
你是说我学习台词的能力有一天会离开我吗？我只是要说出来。这是我所拥有的全部。史上最伟大的人之一。是的。我告诉你，杰森可以看一页纸，你说那是因为一旦那个消失了。我就完蛋了。
Not for you. You're on so many drugs. You're not aging anymore. I mean, you look so much, I don't even know what it is that where do you import it from? It's pretty. That's my question. All the serums. I know you're not.
不是为你。你用了那么多药。你不再变老了。我的意思是，你看上去那么多，我甚至不知道那是什么，你从哪里进口的？这很漂亮。这是我的问题。所有的精华液。我知道你不是。
It's the serums. It's the serums guys. And probably the. It's a facial toner. A lot of niacin or something. No, it's a facial toner. And then if there's a new eye cream that Amanda gave me. And I wear.
是精华液。是精华液伙计们。可能还有。是面部爽肤水。很多烟酰胺之类的。不，是面部爽肤水。然后如果有一种阿曼达给我的新眼霜。我戴着。
Get your money back. Get your money back. Wait, why? The receipt. All right. Now hang on a second. Who was your biggest influence growing up? Well, my dad loved Paul Newman movies.
拿回你的钱。拿回你的钱。等等，为什么？收据。好吧，现在等一下。你成长过程中最大的影响是谁？嗯，我爸爸喜欢保罗·纽曼的电影。
And so. Well, that's why you did. Does that why you did the voice in the documentary? Definitely. When I saw Cool Hand Luke, that changed my idea of what actors and movie stars and movies could do. I wrote a paper on it in college. I loved it so much.
所以。嗯，这就是为什么你做了。这就是为什么你在纪录片里配音吗？绝对。当我看到《铁窗喋血》时，那改变了我对演员、电影明星和电影能做什么的想法。我在大学里写了一篇关于它的论文。我太喜欢它了。
And so when Ethan was doing that thing on Paul Newman, of course, I wanted to be a part of it. But the, the, the stage to my mom, because we were born on Long Island, my mom would take us into the city to see plays and our net summers out there. What's that? Will. I, I spend time, I spend time on Long Island in the summertime. Yeah.
所以当伊桑在做关于保罗·纽曼的那件事时，我当然想参与其中。但是，舞台对我妈妈来说，因为我们出生在长岛，我妈妈会带我们进城看戏，我们在那里度过夏天。那是什么？威尔。我，我花时间，我花时间在长岛度过夏天。是的。
You do in Washington. Just like they're like in the center of it. I mean, just east of there. That's exit 34, exit 35. Yeah. It is exit 34. Like near. You go further.
你在华盛顿。就像他们在中心一样。我的意思是，就在那东边。那是34号出口，35号出口。是的。确实是34号出口。像附近。你走得更远。
East. I go a little further east and a little further south, but still on the island, right? Like it's still on the island for sure. Yeah. For sure. Just past Manorville. Okay. And past fog and everything.
东边。我走得更远一点，更南一点，但仍然在岛上，对吧？就像它肯定还在岛上。是的。肯定的。就在曼诺维尔过去。好的。还有雾气和一切。
Is it getting a little bit past even. Is it past Sabonic, you know, that golf course. Sabonic. Is it a little past? It's a little past. A handsome. So that's not where I was from. Okay.
它是不是有点过去甚至。它是不是过了萨博尼克，你知道，那个高尔夫球场。萨博尼克。是不是有点过去？它有点过去。一个英俊的。所以那不是我来自的地方。好的。
Yeah. That's that. Manhasnet. Manhasnet. Manhasnet. Manhasnet is actually closer to Port Washington. It's not, it's kind of one town over basically. Correct.
是的。那是那个。曼哈塞特。曼哈塞特。曼哈塞特。曼哈塞特其实离华盛顿港更近。它不是，它基本上就是一个镇。没错。
It is one town over. In fact, that's where we shot the exteriors for Hello Tomorrow. And the hospital that was on the call sheet was the hospital that I was born in North Shore Hospital. So I was playing my father in the town where I was first born. It was a pretty. Wait. No way Billy.
它就是一个镇。事实上，那就是我们拍摄《明天，你好》外景的地方。而且通告单上的医院就是我出生的医院，北岸医院。所以我是在我出生的地方扮演我父亲。这真是个。等等。不可能，比利。
Yeah. Yeah. That's where they get the exclamation point from. Because it's like. Because today is too much. And now a word from our sponsor. SmartList is sponsored by BetterHelp. So we all like to feel our best self, right?
是的。是的。这就是他们得到感叹号的地方。因为就像。因为今天太多了。现在是我们赞助商的话。SmartList由BetterHelp赞助。所以我们都喜欢感觉自己是最好的自己，对吧？
And I feel my best self when I am infusing my values into my life. So there's a lot of things that you value, right? So for example, like I value nature. I like, I enjoy the outdoors and stuff like that. So if I go for a walk or a hike or I'm, you know, up in the mountains somewhere, whatever, I value that. And it makes me feel good and it makes me feel like my best self. So it's important to surround yourself with the things that you value in life, right?
当我把我的价值观融入我的生活时，我感觉自己是最好的。所以有很多你重视的事情，对吧？所以例如，我重视自然。我喜欢，我享受户外活动之类的。所以如果我去散步或徒步旅行，或者我，你知道，在山上的某个地方，无论什么，我重视那个。这让我感觉很好，让我感觉自己是最好的自己。所以用你生活中重视的事情包围自己很重要，对吧？
So when you're at your best, you can do great things. But sometimes life gets you bogged down and you may feel overwhelmed or like you're not showing up in the way that you want to. Working with a therapist can help you get closer to the best version of you. Because when you feel empowered, you're more prepared to take on everything life throws at you. If you're thinking of giving therapy a try, better help is a great option. It's convenient, flexible, affordable and entirely online.
所以当你处于最佳状态时，你可以做伟大的事情。但有时候生活让你陷入困境，你可能会感到不知所措，或者觉得你没有以你想要的方式表现出来。与治疗师合作可以帮助你更接近最好的自己。因为当你感到被赋权时，你更有准备去应对生活抛给你的任何事情。如果你正在考虑尝试治疗，BetterHelp是一个很好的选择。它方便、灵活、实惠，而且完全在线。
Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. If you want to live a more empowered life, therapy can get you there. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlist today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash smartlist. Smartlist is supported by Zip Recruiter. Hey, contrary to current headlines, several industries are heading for a hiring boom this spring, including e-commerce, healthcare and surprisingly, hospitality.
只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可与持证治疗师匹配，并随时免费更换治疗师。如果你想过上更有权力的生活，治疗可以让你实现。今天访问betterhelp.com/smartlist，首次月费可享10%的折扣。那是betterhelp, H-E-L-P点com/smartlist。SmartList由Zip Recruiter支持。嘿，与当前的头条新闻相反，几个行业在今年春天正走向招聘热潮，包括电子商务、医疗保健，令人惊讶的是，酒店业。
It's one of the areas with the most growth. Not only does this industry need to hire for service positions, but also managerial positions and back office operations positions. So if you need to hire qualified candidates ASAP for any of these industries or any other industry, you need Zip Recruiter. And right now you can try it for free at ziprecruiter.com slash smartlist. How can Zip Recruiter help grow your team? Zip Recruiter uses its powerful matching technology to find the qualified candidates for a wide
这是增长最快的领域之一。这个行业不仅需要招聘服务职位，还需要管理职位和后台运营职位。所以如果你需要尽快为这些行业或任何其他行业招聘合格的候选人，你需要Zip Recruiter。现在你可以在ziprecruiter.com/smartlist免费试用。Zip Recruiter如何帮助发展你的团队？Zip Recruiter使用其强大的匹配技术为广泛的
range of roles. See a candidate who'd be perfect for your job? Zip Recruiter makes it easy to send them a personal invite so they're more likely to apply. Zip Recruiter also offers attention grabbing labels that speak to job flexibility like urgent, training provided, remote and more. Let Zip Recruiter keep your team growing strong no matter what the industry. Four out of five employers who post on Zip Recruiter get a quality candidate within the first day. See for yourself, go to this exclusive web address to try Zip Recruiter for free.
角色寻找合格的候选人。看到一个非常适合你工作的候选人了吗？Zip Recruiter让你很容易发送个人邀请，所以他们更有可能申请。Zip Recruiter还提供吸引注意力的标签，说明工作灵活性，如紧急、提供培训、远程等。让Zip Recruiter保持你的团队强劲增长，无论什么行业。在Zip Recruiter上发布职位的雇主中，五分之四在第一天内就能获得高质量的候选人。亲自看看，去这个独家网址免费试用Zip Recruiter。
Ziprecruiter.com slash smartlist. Again, that's Ziprecruiter.com slash SMARTLESS. Zip Recruiter, the smartest way to hire. If I'm at a party, I'm having people over. I'm watching the game or whatever. I just feel like it's always one of those moments of like, hey, can I get you something? And I'm like, yeah, can I get a Diet Coke? It feels so good saying that.
Ziprecruiter.com/smartlist。再说一次，那是Ziprecruiter.com/SMARTLESS。Zip Recruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。如果我在聚会上，我邀请人们过来。我在看比赛什么的。我只是觉得这总是那种时刻，嘿，我能给你拿点什么吗？我说，是的，我能来杯健怡可乐吗？说那句话感觉真好。
If I'm at a party or at a restaurant or even if I'm just at home, I guess I don't ask anybody. When I'm at home, I guess I just ask myself for one. I'm kind of like internally going, can I get a Diet Coke? And the answer is always yes. This year, Diet Coke is celebrating people who enjoy life without worrying too much about what those around them think. Diet Coke is the fuel to unapologetically just live your life and love what you love. I love that Diet Coke is in its 40th year because I think that your 40s are when your confidence peak and you become the best version of yourself.
如果我在聚会上或餐厅里，或者即使我只是在家里，我想我不会问任何人。当我在家里时，我想我只是问自己要一杯。我有点像在内心说，我能来杯健怡可乐吗？答案总是肯定的。今年，健怡可乐正在庆祝那些享受生活而不必太担心周围人想法的人。健怡可乐是毫无歉意地过你的生活并热爱你所爱之物的燃料。我喜欢健怡可乐进入第40个年头，因为我认为你的40多岁是你的自信达到顶峰，你成为最好的自己的时候。
Freedom that comes with abandoning the shoulds in life and just loving what you love. And just know if you're having a Diet Coke wherever you are, I probably am too. So join us in grabbing a Diet Coke, doing what you love the most, whatever it is, love what you love. And now back to the show. Now, when you were at NYU, not getting a PhD, do you still use things that you learned there while getting just your masters? Or do you feel like... First of all, you are impressive, Jason. I will say that.
放弃生活中那些“应该”的自由，只是热爱你所爱的东西。只要知道如果你在任何地方喝健怡可乐，我可能也在喝。所以加入我们，拿一杯健怡可乐，做你最喜欢的事情，无论是什么，热爱你所爱的东西。现在回到节目。现在，当你在纽约大学时，没有拿到博士学位，你还在使用你在那里只拿到硕士学位时学到的东西吗？或者你觉得……首先，你令人印象深刻，杰森。我会说那个。
To make getting a master's in anything sound like a disappointment. That's a rare gift. Well, some people stick with it and some people don't. You should see us because they're in tears. You broke up there just for a second there. Will, what did you say? Do you still... I mean, like, I would imagine, let me guess here. I would imagine the stuff that you learned there, which is good, high quality acting lessons. High quality.
让获得任何硕士学位听起来像是一种失望。这是一种罕见的天赋。嗯，有些人坚持到底，有些人没有。你应该看看我们，因为他们泪流满面。你刚才断开了，就一秒钟。威尔，你说了什么？你还在……我的意思是，就像，我猜这里。我猜你在那里学到的东西，那是好的，高质量的表演课程。高质量的。
You use more in theater than you do in television or film, correct or not correct? Some of the tools for using your body in an expansive way, if you know what I mean, Caligula, are best exhibited, yes, on stage. If I had one of those Tivo 10 second things here, I would back that up. Back it up? I would listen up, Will's, fuck yeah, of a bunch of stuff. You better fucking finish with the direction you're going. Finish, keep fucking eye contact here. Keep goddamn eye contact.
你在戏剧中使用的比在电视或电影中多，正确还是不正确？一些以广阔方式使用你身体的工具，如果你明白我的意思，卡里古拉，最好地展示，是的，在舞台上。如果我这里有一个Tivo 10秒的东西，我会把它倒回去。倒回去？我会听着，威尔的，他妈的，一堆东西。你最好他妈的用你正在走的方向完成。完成，保持他妈的眼神接触。保持该死的眼神接触。
So finish the story, Billy. So it is not... Look at Will's square, finish the story. I have found that on stage, you can apply many of the skills. However, with this part that I'm doing right now, it simply would not be possible not to have acquired the skills that we did in graduate school. Because my mouth doesn't move as fast as this guy's does. I think if we're going to build a clickable headline here, we're going to say,
所以完成故事，比利。所以它不是……看着威尔的方块，完成故事。我发现舞台上，你可以应用许多技能。然而，对于我现在正在做的这个角色，如果不获得我们在研究生院学到的技能，根本是不可能的。因为我的嘴没有这家伙动得那么快。我想如果我们要在标题上建立一个可点击的标题，我们会说，
Billy needs no acting lessons whatsoever to take on the character of... Which Apple show are we talking about right now? I was talking about The Morning Show. The Morning Show. It takes no talent to do... You may have just heard me, or perhaps the rigor that we put into setting up this system that I've got in my home now has not been effective and you didn't hear me. Point was...
比利根本不需要任何表演课程来扮演……我们现在在谈论哪个苹果节目？我刚才在谈论《早间新闻》。《早间新闻》。做这个不需要天赋……你可能刚才听到了我，或者也许我们现在在家里设置的这个系统的严谨性并没有生效，你没听到我。重点是……
The work. Did you hear Will? I did, but I just want to implore you, because I think Jason said putting you into a trap because as we both, as we all know, there's one critic who, were she to read The Morning Show, just takes... It's a breeze for me to do, and I don't have to put in any work. There's only one critic, and she listens to every episode, and your fucking phone will blow up, Billy, so fucking fast.
工作。你听到威尔了吗？我听到了，但我只是想恳求你，因为我认为杰森说把你带进了一个陷阱，因为我们都知道，有一位评论家，如果她读到《早间新闻》，只是采取……对我来说这很容易，我不需要投入任何工作。只有一个评论家，她听每一集，你的他妈的手机会爆炸，比利，他妈的快。
Yeah, check your email. Again, I would like to... Aniston just fired you. I should just go get my iPad and show you my application that has the notes in there. But for this particular character, I have to employ every single device that I have at my disposal, which include... This is the one with the exclamation mark? Memorization...
是的，检查你的电子邮件。再说一次，我想……安妮斯顿刚解雇了你。我应该去拿我的iPad，向你展示我的应用程序，里面有笔记。但对于这个特定的角色，我必须使用我所掌握的每一个设备，包括……这是那个带感叹号的吗？记忆……
No, this is The Morning Show. We're still on The Morning Show. Okay, so hello tomorrow. I'm playing a version of my dad, and he speaks a lot slower. I just had to connect to some emotions and some existential despair. In The Morning Show, there are no emotions. He's really enjoying his position in life, but he does speak very fast. So that's one thing I don't do.
不，这是《早间新闻》。我们还在《早间新闻》上。好的，所以《明天，你好》。我扮演我父亲的一个版本，他说话慢得多。我只是不得不连接到一些情绪和一些存在主义的绝望。在《早间新闻》里，没有情绪。他真的很享受他在生活中的位置，但他说话确实非常快。所以那是我不做的一件事。
He speaks slow, and I am connected to my emotions, Jason. Okay? I have feelings. So, Billy, you did... You have spent a lot of time in... You talked about the theater. You spent a lot of time early on. Actually, we were mentioning Ethan.
他说话慢，而且我连接到我的情绪，杰森。好的？我有感觉。所以，比利，你做了……你花了很多时间在……你谈到了戏剧。你早期花了很多时间。事实上，我们提到了伊桑。
Didn't you and Ethan Hock at one point do like two or three plays in a row? We most certainly did, Will. It was a few years running. Thank you for bringing that up. I know Jason wasn't going to. It was called Coast of Utopia, and I will now do all three plays for Jason playing each part. Coast of Utopia is the play you won the Tony for, correct? That is correct, and that was written by Tom Stoppard.
你和伊桑·霍克在某个时候不是连续演了两三部戏吗？我们当然演了，威尔。那是几年连续的。谢谢你提到这一点。我知道杰森不会。它叫《乌托邦海岸》，我现在要为杰森演完所有三部戏，扮演每个角色。《乌托邦海岸》是你获得托尼奖的戏，对吧？那是正确的，那是汤姆·斯托帕德写的。
There's a big deal. As Jason knows, it was about Russian philosophers at the turn of the century. Yes. And if you can imagine an 11... Very underreported on that. If you can imagine an 11-hour meditation on that, that's what you would have gotten if you had seen Coast of Utopia with Ethan and I. And a number of other...
这是一件大事。正如杰森所知，它是关于世纪之交的俄罗斯哲学家。是的。如果你能想象一个11……关于那个的报道非常不足。如果你能想象一个11小时的冥想，如果你看过伊桑和我演的《乌托邦海岸》，那就是你会得到的。还有许多其他……
Was it really 11 hours? Yes, we did... There was three plays that we did in Repertory. So we did the first play on, say, a Tuesday night, and then the second play we would do a Wednesday matinee, and then the third play we would do a Wednesday night, and then we'd start again on Thursday. But then on Saturday, we would do a marathon where at 11 o'clock we would do the first play,
真的有11个小时吗？是的，我们做了……我们演了三部戏，在剧目中。所以我们在，比如说，周二晚上演第一部戏，然后周三下午演第二部戏，然后周三晚上演第三部戏，然后我们周四重新开始。但然后在周六，我们会做一个马拉松，在11点我们会演第一部戏，
then there would be a lunch break, and then at 3 o'clock we would do the next play, and then there would be a dinner break, and then at 8 o'clock we would do the last play. And every single one of those performances, 1,500 people at the Vivien Beaumont Theatre was packed. People liked the event, even if it was about Russian philosophy. Yeah, they liked being a part of it. And my character died in the middle of the second play,
然后会有午餐休息，然后在3点我们会演下一部戏，然后会有晚餐休息，然后在8点我们会演最后一部戏。而且每一场演出，维维安·博蒙特剧院的1500人座无虚席。人们喜欢这个活动，即使它是关于俄罗斯哲学的。是的，他们喜欢成为其中的一部分。而且我的角色在第二部戏中间死了，
so I got to get on my little Vespa, wheel my ass home, have a little nap, maybe cook some dinner for my son, and then take the Vespa back up to Lincoln Center for the curtain call at 11 o'clock. Yeah, yeah. Wow, about that. Wow. Do you have, like, when you're a younger actor, though,
所以我可以骑上我的小Vespa，把我的屁股骑回家，小睡一会儿，也许给我儿子做点晚饭，然后把Vespa骑回林肯中心参加11点的谢幕。是的，是的。哇，关于那个。哇。当你是一个年轻演员时，虽然
first of all, we chatted on my other podcast called Hypocondreactor quite a while ago. Wait, what's it called? How to Blast. What's it called? Where do we find it? It's fine, anyway. So listen, but I never asked you this because you're in some of my favorite movies. We talked about this before.
首先，很久以前我们在我的另一个播客《Hypocondreactor》上聊过。等等，它叫什么来着？《How to Blast》？它叫什么？我们在哪里能找到它？算了，没关系。听着，我从来没问过你这个，因为你演过我最喜欢的一些电影。我们之前聊过这个。
Name one. I got Alien Covenant. Good. Mission Impossible 3? Was it 2, 3, 4? Yeah. But anyway, tons of stuff. Spotlight.
随便说一部。我有《异形：契约》。很好。《碟中谍3》？是2、3还是4？对。但总之，有很多作品。《聚焦》。
You were in Spotlight, which I love. By the way, Billy, your name came up when we had Krasinski on a few weeks ago, and we were talking about that scene where you and Cruz are mouthing to each other, because they're speaking, but you're not saying anything, and we were talking, because we love that scene. I love when you do that. When you were younger, though, and you got some of these big jobs, like working with Ridley Scott or whoever, Tom Cruise or, you know,
你演了《聚焦》，我很喜欢那部电影。顺便说一下，比利，几周前我们请克拉辛斯基来的时候提到了你的名字，我们当时在聊你和克鲁兹在那场戏里互相做口型的那一段，因为他们当时在说话，但你们什么都没说，我们当时在聊这个，因为我们很喜欢那场戏。我很喜欢你那样做。不过，当你年轻的时候，接到一些大工作，比如和雷德利·斯科特或者其他人，汤姆·克鲁斯，或者，你知道的，
you weren't almost famous too, weren't you, I think? Yeah. Yeah, Cameron Crow. Like when you're younger and you're like working with these bigger names, directors or whatever it is, where don't you kind of freak out? Like, I can't believe I'm here. I can't believe I'm here. I can't believe I got the part.
你还演了《几近成名》，对吧？我想是这样。对，对，卡梅伦·克罗。当你年轻的时候，和这些大人物、导演或者其他什么人合作，难道不会感到恐慌吗？就像，我不敢相信我在这里。我不敢相信我在这里。我不敢相信我得到了这个角色。
I can't, you know what I mean? Like for me, I would be like, I don't know, it would be distracting almost. Like I couldn't get past. Oh my God, I'm working with Ridley Scott. It's awful. Yeah. No, it's an absolutely terrible experience. Really?
我不能，你明白我的意思吗？对我来说，我会觉得，我不知道，这几乎会让我分心。就像我无法跨过那道坎。天哪，我在和雷德利·斯科特合作。这太糟糕了。是吗？不，这绝对是一次糟糕的经历。真的吗？
Because the only thing you can do is react the opposite way, because you don't want to be fired. So you end up acting overconfident and pissing off the people that you've admired, because you're just trying to act like you're not going to shit yourself, which is all you're thinking about. Is that true? Is that true? Oh, I was doing, Barry Levinson.
因为你唯一能做的就是做出相反的反应，因为你不想被解雇。所以你最终表现得过于自信，惹恼了你所钦佩的人，因为你只是试图表现得好像你不会吓得屁滚尿流，而这正是你脑子里唯一想的事情。是真的吗？是真的吗？哦，我当时在和巴里·莱文森合作。
I loved his movies growing up. The influences like Diner and the whole Baltimore trilogy, Avalon. The Tin Men actually is, do you guys remember that movie? For sure. Guys who sold aluminum side. Richard Dreyfus. Yeah. Richard Dreyfus, exactly.
我从小就喜欢他的电影。像《餐馆》和整个巴尔的摩三部曲，《阿瓦隆》这样的作品对我影响很大。《锡人》其实，你们还记得那部电影吗？当然。卖铝制壁板的家伙们。理查德·德莱福斯。对，理查德·德莱福斯，没错。
So there's a lot of, Hello Tomorrow has a lot of the same kind of spirit, you know, that Glen Gary, Glen Ross. We got, you can sell your way into a better future. And it doesn't matter what you're selling, the product is irrelevant. Now I'm, you can, as an American, where the, just take some gumption, the land of opportunities selling is the purest example of that. Jason, Jason takes two gumptions every night before bed, right? Sure.
所以有很多，《明日之间》也有很多那种精神，你知道，就像《拜金一族》。我们有，你可以通过销售来换取更好的未来。无论你在卖什么，产品本身并不重要。现在我，你可以，作为一个美国人，只要有胆识，这片充满机会的土地，销售就是最纯粹的例子。杰森，杰森每天睡前都要吃两份胆识，对吧？当然。
Are you up to two? You're up to two. Wait a second. Yeah. And one before a podcast. It helps. It helps. Now I want to talk about.
你吃到两份了？你吃到两份了。等一下。对，播客前还要吃一份。有帮助。有帮助。现在我想谈谈。
No, hang on. He's making a point. He's making a point. Yes, please. Land the plane. Sorry. Right. No, no, no.
不，等等。他在讲重点。他在讲重点。是的，请继续。把飞机降落吧。抱歉。对。不，不，不。
The, one of the first things I did was he directed sleepers. And that was starring everybody. Yeah. Robert De Niro, Dustin Hoffman. Yeah. Brad Pitt amongst others. Kevin Bacon. I was shitting myself.
我做的第一件事之一是他导演的《沉睡者》。那部电影众星云集。对。罗伯特·德尼罗，达斯汀·霍夫曼。对。布拉德·皮特等等。凯文·贝肯。我当时吓得要死。
This was your first film, wasn't it? Kevin Bacon. It was, it was, I did one independent movie. But I don't know if you guys saw it called Grind. No, but add an R onto that. I know, but you have the, Sean has the app though, don't you? It's different. Am I thinking of the same thing?
这是你的第一部电影，不是吗？凯文·贝肯。是，是，我拍过一部独立电影。但我不知道你们有没有看过，叫《Grind》。没有，但在后面加个R。我知道，但你有，肖恩有那个应用，对吧？那不一样。我想的是同一件事吗？
Okay. I want to get to the film you did called Pillow Man. No, I want to talk about Barry Levinson. Barry Levinson has to play. I want him to finish with Barry Levinson. So. Oh, sorry. So you're admiring Barry.
好吧。我想聊聊你拍的那部叫《枕头人》的电影。不，我想谈谈巴里·莱文森。巴里·莱文森得演。我想让他把巴里·莱文森的话题说完。所以。哦，抱歉。所以你在钦佩巴里。
So to Sean's point before, it, the last thing that you think to do is act giddy, you know, because first of all, we're playing gangsters. But secondly, you, you have to feel like you, you want to make them feel like you fit in, that you can handle the job. So consequently, you miss the opportunity to tell them all how much you love them, how much their, their work has inspired you throughout your life. So I was thinking about, because when I did Without Limits, which was about this runner, Steve Prefontein, Robert Town directed it.
所以回到肖恩之前的观点，你最不会做的事情就是表现得轻浮，你知道，因为首先，我们演的是黑帮。但其次，你必须让他们觉得你很合群，你能胜任这份工作。因此，你错过了告诉他们你有多爱他们，他们的作品在你一生中给了你多少启发的机会。所以我当时在想，因为当我拍《永无止境》时，那是关于那个跑步运动员史蒂夫·普雷方丹的，罗伯特·汤恩导演的。
And he was like always thoughtful and poetic and a bit cantankerous and stuff. And so like we were constantly working together, trying to figure out the script, but Conrad Hall was shooting it. And now as an adult, the fact that I didn't spend all the time asking him every possible question I could about the incredible career that he had had up to that point, rather than screaming at him that I understood the character better than he did. That would have been a memorable way. You never know if the person wants to talk about all that or not.
他总是深思熟虑、富有诗意，还有点脾气暴躁之类的。所以我们一直在合作，试图弄清楚剧本，但康拉德·霍尔在拍摄。现在作为一个成年人，我没有花时间问他关于他当时所拥有的不可思议的职业生涯的每一个可能的问题，而是对他大喊大叫，说我比他更了解这个角色。那才是一种令人难忘的方式。你永远不知道对方是否想谈论所有这些。
You know, it's a delicate kind of thing. Like for sure. But those are those, those are those things of like, as you get older, you, you, you, you're able to appreciate in a way that you couldn't when you're that young, of course. Right. Yeah, exactly. And the idea that you can take a moment to go like, Hey, I really appreciate what you've done.
你知道，这是一种微妙的事情。确实。但这些就是那种，随着年龄增长，你能够以一种年轻时无法做到的方式去欣赏的事情，当然。对。是的，完全正确。而且你可以花点时间说，嘿，我真的很欣赏你所做的一切。
I need to tell you this and I want to carve some time out. And I feel like Jason, do you want to, I'll give you a minute here. Jason's created that actually. He was like that on the longest week, every single day, he would start with a positive affirmation with me. He would bring me a clip from either something I did on film or read to me something, a review of me on stage, just to keep, you know, my chance because he's a veteran. He's been working since he was two.
我需要告诉你这一点，我想腾出一些时间。我觉得杰森，你想，我给你一分钟。杰森确实创造了这一点。他在《最漫长的一周》里就是这样，每天他都会以积极的肯定开始和我交流。他会给我带来一段我拍电影的片段，或者给我读一段我在舞台上的评论，只是为了保持，你知道，我的状态，因为他是个老手。他从两岁起就开始工作了。
I was, you know, late to the game. I didn't start professionally working clubs in my late 20s. All right. I did ask you quite a bit about how you kept your water weight down during the pre-fontein thing. Right. So, Jason has a photo of you. Jason has a photo of you at the end of his treadmill and that's what keeps him going.
我，你知道，入行比较晚。我直到20多岁才开始在俱乐部专业工作。好吧。我确实问过你不少关于你在普雷方丹那部戏期间是如何控制水分的。对。所以，杰森在跑步机末端有一张你的照片，那就是他坚持下去的动力。
Just stares at it. Hey, what about, did you have to like turn into a long distance runner for pre-fontein? Great question. No. And I did not have to turn into a killer for sleepers. Nobody asked that one. Sometimes it's just pretend. It's just pretend.
只是盯着它看。嘿，关于那个，你为了普雷方丹不得不变成一个长跑运动员吗？好问题。没有。而且我为了《沉睡者》也不必变成一个杀手。没人问过那个。有时候这只是假装。这只是假装。
It's called acting. Jason, look into it. You did. When they, thank God. There was a woman on it who was our consultant, our running consultant, because she had, she was a professional runner. She ran in the Olympics and she was also in personal best, which was Robert Town's first movie on running.
这叫表演。杰森，研究一下。你做到了。当他们，谢天谢地。上面有一位女士是我们的顾问，我们的跑步顾问，因为她，她是一名职业跑步者。她参加过奥运会，她还出演了《个人最佳》，那是罗伯特·汤恩的第一部关于跑步的电影。
With Margot Hemingway. Marielle Hemingway. Marielle Hemingway. And so she understood the difference between running as a sport and running on film. And it turns out when you run on film, you're only doing intervals. So you don't want to ever train for more than 200 meters because the camera is not going to do like a pan of the entire stadium. So you're going to do little segments at a time for each part of the race.
和玛戈·海明威一起。玛丽尔·海明威。玛丽尔·海明威。所以她理解作为一项运动的跑步和在电影中跑步的区别。事实证明，当你在电影中跑步时，你只是在做间歇跑。所以你永远不想训练超过200米，因为摄像机不会拍摄整个体育场的全景。所以你会在比赛的每一部分做一小段一小段的动作。
So what she trained me to do was intervals. And, you know, it was funny. Some of the professional runners, they wanted to keep just running and running and running. And she was right. They would burn out by the end of the day. They were done. And, but, you know, it does, it does. You do that, right?
所以她训练我做的是间歇跑。而且，你知道，这很有趣。一些职业跑步者，他们想一直跑一直跑。她是对的。他们会在一天结束时精疲力竭。他们完了。但是，你知道，确实，确实。你这样做，对吧？
For intervals of, you said you've had a lot of intervals that you've had the runs now for about two months, haven't you? Will cracked himself up on that one. But I managed to, I plowed through, I plowed through him. Hey, Bill. Now this is a chat chat chat bot 499, whatever that new A.I. thing. Yeah, that's it. So 499 chat bot wants to know what, what do you feel your most underrated performances
关于间歇，你说你现在已经跑了大约两个月了，不是吗？威尔在那一点上把自己逗乐了。但我设法，我坚持了下来，我坚持了下来。嘿，比尔。现在这个聊天聊天聊天机器人499，不管那个新的人工智能是什么。对，就是那个。所以499聊天机器人想知道，你觉得你最被低估的表演是什么
and then as a follow up, what's your most overrated? Oh my God. He put, he put, he put in, what were your search terms into chat? You fucking psycho. And did it, did it, did it, did it reveal Billy's answers? A lot of this is for Billy Corbin, but I'm just, I think this works. I think my most underrated performance is in Ozark and the most. God, why did we cut you out?
然后作为后续，你最被高估的是什么？天哪。他放了，他放了，他放了，你在聊天里搜索了什么词？你这个该死的疯子。它揭示了比利的答案了吗？很多是给比利·科尔宾的，但我只是，我觉得这行得通。我觉得我最被低估的表演是在《黑钱胜地》里，而最。天哪，我们为什么要剪掉你的戏份？
I know. I think that's one of the reasons. Over, nearly everything. Everything's overrated? It's a shame that I'm on your program because it's, it's, it's signaled the beginning of the decline for you all. Meaning this is the peak right now? Well, you have, the Zenith was just over here and like this arrived on the radar as soon
我知道。我想那是原因之一。被高估，几乎所有东西。所有东西都被高估了？我很遗憾我出现在你的节目上，因为它标志着你们所有人衰落的开始。意思是现在是巅峰吗？好吧，你拥有，天顶就在这里，而这就像一旦你得到了一些船员的魔法，它就出现在雷达上。我想知道，这是聊天机器人想知道的另一件事。阿奇被锁在外面了。抱歉。阿奇被锁在外面了。你离开了吗？我们没注意到。所以你是《明日之间》的执行制片人。
as you got some crewed up magic. I want to know, here's something else chat bot wants to know. Archie was locked out. Sorry. Archie was locked out. Were you gone? We didn't notice. So you're an EP on Hello Tomorrow.
你是，对于特雷西来说，这意味着执行制片人。当然。除了艾琳·卡什什安通过让你担任那个职位、那个薪水而给你的不可思议的合同福利之外。我的意思是，吉米·达莫迪知道怎么做。而吉米·达莫迪，另一个伟大的高尔夫球手。现在，你作为执行制片人在做什么？你作为执行制片人在外面吗？
You are, and for Tracy, that means executive producer. Sure. Aside from the incredible contractual perk that Aline Kashishian gave you by getting you that, that position, that salary. I mean, Jimmy Darmady knows how to do it. And Jimmy Darmady, another great golfer. Now, what are you doing as EP? Are you out there as executive producer?
你在挥鞭子吗？你在不演戏的日子里出现在片场吗？一片沉默。我在我们那部戏里没做多少那种事。但是，但我看了样片。我在那里。我在看剪辑。对。
You're cracking the whip. Are you showing up on set on the days you're not acting? A lot of silence. I didn't do a lot of that on us. But, but I was watching dailies. I'm in there. I'm looking at cuts. Yeah.
所以我，我会坦率地说。我不是那个想法的领导者。我在合同谈判完成后被告知我是这个节目的制片人。你在这里表现得非常、非常谦虚，我是在逗你，但你，你是那里的智囊团的一部分，正在对那个节目做一些事情，这比你作为演员能做的要多。是的。
So I'll be, I'll be frank. I was not the, I was not in the lead on that idea. I was informed after the contract negotiations were completed that I was a producer on this program. You're being very, you're being very, very modest here and I'm teasing you a bit, but you're, you're, you're a part of the brain trust there that's, that's doing stuff to that show that is more than what you could do as an actor. Yes.
好吧，让我们这么说吧，比利，我帮你一把。让我们说你职业生涯到了某个点。这通常也伴随着经验，它给了你在谈判桌上的发言权，让你能够参与关于创意决策的对话。创意，你正在从事的任何事情的创意方向。你赢得了这一点，能够去说。对，因为如果你只是一个受雇的演员，你，你可以，作为演员，你可以说，我不知道这个，但他们可以去说，好吧，我们会考虑的。作为执行制片人，你可以说，嘿，我的声音，我对此有一票投票权。你喜欢那样吗，比利？你，你，你。所以它占用了。我要认真回答这个问题。好吧。对。
Well, let's just say Billy, I'll help you out here. Let's just say that you get to a certain point in your career. And this is especially often comes with experience as well, that it gives you a voice at the table that allows you to participate in conversations about creative decisions. Creative, creative direction of whatever it is you're working on. And you've earned that to be able to go. Yeah. Cause if you're just an actor for hire, you, you can, as the actor, you can go, I don't
我的意思是，深呼吸。我不逗你了。好吧。所以我一直认为自己是一个诠释者。那是我们的时间。抱歉。抱歉。一秒钟。
know about this, but they can go, okay, well, we'll take that on board. As an EP, you can go, Hey, my voice, I get a vote on this. And are you enjoying that Billy? Are you, are you, are you. So it's taken up. I'm going to answer this seriously. Okay. Yeah.
但我们会让你回来的。回到华盛顿。大粉丝。好吧。我从来没谈过当小丑和我的年轻思维工作。不，说真的。继续。继续。
I mean, deep breath. I'll stop teasing. Okay. So I've always thought of myself as an interpretive. That's our time. Sorry. Sorry. One second.
继续。还有，我的第一份工作是当重演者。我们稍后会回到那个话题。好吧。所以我认为自己。我不是像你们三位那样，我相信可以创造事物，自己写东西，和朋友合作剧本，即兴创作的人。
But we're going to have you back. Back to Washington. Big fans. Okay. I never talked about being a clown and my young mind work. No, seriously. Go ahead. Go ahead.
我读了一些东西。如果它触动了我，或者其中的某一部分触动了我，我就想做。如果我不理解它，或者其中有一部分我根本不理解，我就不做。我不会去说，哦，我明白在第三幕，我们只需要润色一下那里的对抗。那家伙太快达到他弧线的顶峰了。
Go ahead. Also, my first job was as a reenactor. We'll get back to that though. Okay. So I have thought of myself. I am not somebody who like the three of you, I'm sure can create things, write things themselves, collaborate with a friend on a script, improve.
然后我们最后20分钟在做什么？我只是不那样想。我想，好吧，这个素材里有些东西我觉得能构成一个激动人心的故事。我打赌我能在那部分提供帮助。如果导演能解释他们计划如何让那个故事以我能理解的方式变得栩栩如生，那么我就做，我把一切都留给导演，
I read something. And if it speaks to me or some part of it speaks to me, I want to do it. If I don't understand it or there's a part of it that I don't understand at all, I don't do it. I don't go, Oh, I understand in the third act, we just need to polish on the antagonism there. The guy gets to the peak of his arc too soon.
一切，所有的制作，所有的剪辑。当然，我们谈论我对角色的诠释，以及在拍摄的那一刻，在从糟糕到可怕的范围内它处于什么位置，以及我能做些什么来改进并兑现我的承诺。但我不会去说，让我进入剪辑室。对，让我修补它。我从来没想过，啊，我知道这部电影该怎么拍。
And then what are we doing for the last 20 minutes? I just don't think like that. I think, okay, there's something about this material that I think makes for an exciting story. And I bet I could help with that part. And if the director can explain the way in which they plan on making that story come to life in a way that I can understand, then I do it and I leave everything to the director,
对，我本可以。现在它只是不是一部分。我的意思是，贾斯汀从，你知道，我30年前认识他时就有那种本能。他一直想成为那种创意叙事的一部分。而它一直避开我。看看他现在。被捕，监禁，因为，他得到了什么？
everything, all the produce, all the editing. Of course, we talk about my interpretation of the character and how on a scale of bad to terrible where it is at that point in the, in the shoot and what I can do to improve and live up to my promise. But I don't go, let me get into the editor. Yeah, let me fix it. I never think, Ah, I know how this movie would have worked.
10年，我想？大概20年，我想。但当他回来时，我们会在这里。我想在第二秒加入那个，因为我想听你故事的结尾。但他会很棒的。但他会很棒的。他会没事的。但你注意到了吗，你最近没看到照片吗，
Yeah, I could have. Now it's just not a part. I mean, Justin has had that instinct throw since, you know, I knew him 30 years ago. He's wanted to be a part of that creative storytelling. And it has always alluded me. And look at him now. Arrested, incarcerated for, what did he get?
他的手臂变小了一点？好吧，那些会在监狱里练壮的。你打赌。对。对，因为监狱是练手臂的好地方。是个好地方，但我只是，我不知道。我只是觉得他终于赶上他了。所以他看起来不错，而且看起来比实际年龄年轻。
10 years, I think? Kind of a 20, I think. But we're going to be here when he gets back. I wanted to get the throw in a second because I want to hear the end of your story. But he's going to be great. But he's going to be great. And he's going to be okay. But have you noticed, don't you see lately, the photos lately,
现在它真的赶上他了。他看起来没那么火辣。用你寄给他的那盒袖子。这种事发生在每个人身上。但一旦他拿到贾斯汀的烟酸和甜菜根，他就会没事的。等等，比利，你在重演？等等，所以你从来没参与过那个过程？哦，是的。
that his arms have gotten a little bit smaller? Well, those are going to bulk up in prison. You bet you. Yeah. Yeah, because prison is a great place for arms. It's a good place, but I'm just, I don't know. I just sort of feel like he's finally catching up with him. So he's looked good and sort of young for his age.
所以我不想做任何那种事。所以当它真正到来，我们不得不经历选角时，那是第一部分，我得到了某种代理权，用一个更好的词来说，并说也许那就是我们正在寻找的基调。也许我们不需要我们的网。你知道，也许贝特曼对任何事情都不合适。也许，你知道，我的意思是，当谈到那些讨论时，我们能得到更多的海斯吗？有可能吗？
And now it's really catching up to him. He doesn't look so hot. Use that box of sleeves that you sent him. It happens to everybody. But once he gets ahold of Jason's niacin and beetroot, he'll be fine. Wait, Billy, you were reenacting? Wait, so you've never been part of that process? Oh yeah.
它甚至可用吗？不，他有两个播客，那种对话。它们适度令人兴奋。对。但工作是我真正喜欢的。然后当，回到你之前的观点，我确实看了样片，我确实对当我看到组装件时有了一个审查点，我所回应的工作是否真的在剪辑中。
So I didn't want to do any of that. And so when it actually came to this and we had to go through the casting, that was the first part of it where I got to have some agency for lack of a better word and say that maybe that's the tone we're looking for. Maybe we don't need our net. You know, maybe Bateman is not right for anything. Maybe, you know, I mean, when it came to those discussions, can we get more haze? Is there a possibility?
而且我确实施加了相当大的影响力，我对此感到非常自豪。现在，当这个出来时，如果人们对某些我倾向于的镜头有问题，我想我们会知道我是什么样的制片人。这只是很多次要角色在说，嘿，你知道，我得走了。你要早点下班，而你在说，为什么？为什么？是的。你要早点走。
Is it even available? No, he's got two podcasts, those kinds of conversations. They were moderately exciting. Yeah. But the work is what I really liked. And then when, to your point before, I did watch dailies and I got to have a point of review about when I saw the assemblies, whether or not the work that I was responding to was actually in the cut.
现在。你要去船上吗？顺便说一下，那是一场很棒的戏。他上面有游泳池。嘿，我得走了。我得回家了。我只是要出发了。那是美好的一天。
And that I got to exert quite a bit of influence, which I felt very proud about. Now, when this comes out and if people have problems with certain takes that were the ones that I leaned into, I think we'll have an idea of what kind of producer I am. It's just a lot of secondary characters going, hey, you know, I got to take off. You're going to leave early for work and you're going, why? Why? Yes. You're going to leave early.
开始。什么？什么？当你不在你孩子身边时，你不可思议的孩子，我爱他。哦，你做得很好。太棒了。干得好。顺便说一下，他现在在电影学院，想进入那个行业。
Now. What you're going to go to the boat? By the way, that's a great scene. He's got pools up there. Hey, I got to take off. I got to get home. I'm just going to head out. That's a good day.
太酷了。他是个真正的好孩子，你的儿子，威尔。我会说，我已经几年没见他了。我所做的飞跃是，我想大概是10年，从你和我几年前住在那里的时间开始，西好莱坞那个奇怪的地方。威尔当时大概四五岁左右。对。那是对的。
Beginnings. What? What? When you're not with your kid, your incredible kid, I love him. Oh, you've done a good job. Terrific. Well done. By the way, he's in film school right now, looking to get into the business there.
阿奇刚出生，然后切到突然我们就在我们朋友的地方，然后你和我就坐着一个完全成熟的成年人。你说，嘿，这是威尔。我说，等一下。这是你。我有一个关于，你知道，当你，因为你，谢谢。当你大量工作时，看起来你停不下来，其中一部分包括旅行。
That's so cool. He's a real nice kid, your son, Will. And I will say, I hadn't seen him in a few years. The leap I made was, I want to say probably almost 10 years from the time when you and I were staying in that place years ago, that weird place in West Hollywood. And Will was probably four or five or something at the time. Yeah. That's right.
你在逃避什么？那是什么？我在从什么地方呼唤？我以为你要说，你在逃避什么？你不断地，你知道，不同的城市，不同的，不管什么酒店或一个工作室，一个工作室，一居室公寓，不管你说什么。你有没有感觉到一种能量把你拉回家，无论你在哪里？或者你能活在当下说，哦，天哪，这很有趣。
And Archie had just been born and then cut to all of a sudden we were out at our friend's place having, and then there's this like full blown adult sitting next to you between you and me. And you're like, Hey, and this is Will. I go, wait a second. This is you. I have a question about, you know, when you, because you, thank you. When you work a ton and it seems like you don't stop and part of that includes travel.
我喜欢离家这么久。我喜欢这份工作。就像，无论你在哪里，你都能完全活在当下吗？还是你不断地觉得，天哪，我有点希望我在家。肖恩，这是一个伟大的，你知道，我实际上有一段时间没在纽约以外的地方工作了，就是因为那个确切的原因。如果回家的吸引力很强，显然当你有一个孩子在学校时，那是一个很强的吸引力。
What are you running from? What's that? What am I calling from? I thought you were going to say, what are you running from? And you're constantly, you know, different cities, different, whatever hotels or one studio, one studio, one bedroom apartment, whatever you say. Do you ever feel like an energy pulling you home wherever you are? Or can you be present and go, Oh my God, this is fun.
永不停止。还有贾斯汀现在的观点看着他。典型的嘉年华。我也喜欢嘉年华生活。对。就像在路上，但不是我年轻时那样。对。我更喜欢待在家里。
I love being away from home for this long. I like this job. Like, can you be fully present wherever you are? Or do you constantly feel like, God, I kind of wish I was home. Sean, it's a great, you know, I didn't actually spend a lot of time working outside of New York for a while for that exact reason. If the draw of home is pretty strong and obviously when you got a child in school, that's pretty strong draw.
好吧，那么今天对你来说完美的一天是什么样的？就像首先，你会在哪个城市？完美的一天。你在哪个城市？我在纽约。你在纽约。你在做什么？我醒来。
Never stop. And also Jason's point looking at him now. Typical carny. I like the carny life too. Yeah. Like being on the road, but not the way that I did when I was younger. Yeah. I much prefer to be at home.
你几点起床？我大概7点半醒来，喝几杯咖啡。早上。因为我昨晚熬夜看卡罗莱纳篮球赛，我睡到7点半，然后我煮点咖啡，我给我的哥们打电话。所以你煮咖啡。你没有那种可编程的咖啡机吗？我煮咖啡，滴滤咖啡，就像滴滤咖啡，像浓缩咖啡烘焙，加点牛奶
Well, then what would a perfect day be for you today? Like first of all, what city would you be in? Perfect day. What city are you in? I'm in New York. You're in New York. What are you doing? I wake up.
和糖。不错。我把它放进我的外带杯里。我们要去哪？外带杯。当然。你要在你去誓言之前离开家吗？我的女朋友，再见。
What time are you going to get up? I wake up around 7.30, have myself a couple cups of coffee. Morning. Because I was up late watching Carolina basketball and I sleep in till 7.30 and then I make some coffee and I call my buddy. So you make the coffee. You don't have the coffee like one of those programmable? I make the coffee and drip coffee, just drip coffee like an espresso roast, a little milk
他在亲吻人。闭嘴。抱歉。我在高尔夫球场见我的朋友约翰·康纳利，我们俩走大约三个半小时左右。在泽西岛。也许打出80多杆的成绩，在那里吃顿美餐。所以我们还在睡觉。
and sugar. Nice. And I put that in my to-go cup. Where are we going? To-go cup. Sure. You're going to leave the house before you go to your vows? My girlfriend, goodbye.
不。这是，现在我们是，贾斯汀。我以为他在跟我开玩笑。你知道吗，如果我从头开始讲会更好。我回来时更好。好吧。当然。对。
He's kissing people. Shut up. Sorry. I meet my friend John Connelly at the golf course and the two of us walk around in about three and a half hours or so. Out in Jersey. Maybe shoot somewhere in the low 80s, have a nice lunch there. So we're still sleeping.
所以我7点半醒来。7点半，对。不。所以你完成了。所以那是午餐时间。现在你回家了。那是对的。你要。
Nope. This is, now we're, Jason. I thought he was kidding me. You know what, it's better if I take it back from the beginning. It's better when I get back. Okay. Sure. Yeah.
我有个小午睡。当然。好。欢迎来到中年。也许20分钟的强力午睡之类的。洗澡，吃顿早晚餐，因为我和那位女士要去看戏。我们要去看一场演出。那很好。
So I wake up at 7.30. 7.30, yeah. No. So you finish. So that's lunchtime. Now you go home. That's right. And you're going to.
那很好。之后我们见了几位演员。我们还在滚动。然后那是完美的一天。你看什么演出？对。我们喜欢音乐剧吗？
I have a little nap ski. Sure. Good. Welcome to middle age. Maybe 20 minute power nap or something. Shower, have an early dinner because the lady and I are taking in some theater. And we're going to go see a show. That's nice.
现在有什么？这是个好问题。有很多好东西。今年春天有一部很棒的新剧开演。告诉我们，威尔。在贝拉斯科。哦，在贝拉斯科。如果你能买到票的话。
That's nice. And we meet a couple of the cast afterwards. We're still rolling. And then that's a perfect day. What show are you seeing? Yeah. What do we like? We like musical theater?
如果你能买到票的话。它叫。晚安，奥斯卡。晚安，奥斯卡。贝拉斯科。晚安，奥斯卡。它叫。晚安，奥斯卡。
What is up now? That's a great question. There's a lot of good stuff. There's a great new play opening this spring. Tell us, Will. At the Bellasco. Oh, at the Bellasco. If you can get tickets.
晚安，奥斯卡。晚安，奥斯卡。它由我们的肖恩·海斯主演。这到底是怎么回事？那在四月底开演。肖恩·海斯回到百老汇。回到百老汇。这正在发生吗？
If you can get tickets. It's called. Good night, Oscar. Good night, Oscar. The Bellasco. Good night, Oscar. It's called. Good night, Oscar.
对。B-O-B。在伟大的白路上。这是什么时候开的，肖恩？我们都要去。我们都要去。开幕之夜。没压力，比利。
Good night, Oscar. Good night, Oscar. It's starring the our hour, Sean Hayes. What in the world? That opens at the end of April. Sean Hayes back on Broadway. Back on Broadway. Is this happening?
它在4月23日开演。4月23日。对，提到它真好。好吧，开幕之夜是24日。或者24日。也许是24日。对，相信我。24日。
Yeah. B-O-B. On the great white way. When is this open, Sean? We're all going. We're all going. Opening night. No pressure, Billy.
现在，肖恩，你想要我们。四张票？肖恩，你想要我们在开幕之夜吗？还是你想要我们在预演中，这样我们可以给你建议？我实际上真的，真心诚意地不想知道你们是否来。顺便说一下，如果你不来，那也没关系。但如果你来。你在开玩笑吗？
It opens April 23rd. April 23rd. Yeah, that's so nice to mention it. Well, the opening night is the 24th. Or 24th. Maybe it's the 24th. Yeah, trust me. 24th.
我会像。好吧，别听。我们会去的。我们不会让你知道的。但一旦幕布拉开，我们就会去。所以肖恩，进来吧。你们，一个机会。射击。
Now, Sean, would you like us. Four tickets? Sean, would you like us there at opening night? Or do you want us in the previews so we can give you notes? I actually really, truly honestly don't want to know if you guys come. And by the way, if you don't come, that's okay too. But if you do come. Are you kidding?
你能看到，你能听到我吗？肖恩。我能看到他。你不能看到我。你知道吗？在他们那边工作。在我们这边不工作。就像那面反射镜。
I'm going to be like. Okay, don't listen. We'll be there. We won't let you know. But as soon as the curtain goes up, we're going to go. So Sean, come on in. You guys, a chance at shot. Shot.
没门。在芝加哥。等等。就像我们在。比利在芝加哥。你做到了，哈？它正在发生。环顾四周。
Can you see, can you hear me? Sean. I can see him. You can't see me. You know what? Works on their side. Doesn't work on ours. Like that reflective mirror.
再说一遍。享受它。享受它。所以进来。当我们在芝加哥做的时候。在后面走，只是杰克。天哪。这是一个日场观众。
No way. In Chicago. Wait. It's like we're in the. Billy in Chicago. You did it, huh? It's happening. Look around.
绝对，那是日场。日场，就在那里。该死的。好吧，那很令人兴奋。我们能看看那个吗，肖恩？等等，所以比利，我也想在之前得到这个，因为你做了这么多，首先，我们略过了《几近成名》，因为你做了那个，
Say that one again. Enjoy it. Enjoy it. So get in. When we did it in Chicago. way in the back goes, just Jack. Oh my God. This is a matinee audience.
你在那部电影里太棒了，你就像从大炮里射出来一样。它真的让每个人，就像它太棒了。所以我- 你在听吗，贾斯汀？对，不，我，它是- 好吧，那太棒了。让我们强调一下我们会说的。
Absolutely, it was a matinee. Matinee, there it is. Fucking fuck. Well, that's exciting. Can we just see that, Sean? Hang on, so Billy, I wanna get to this too before, because you've done so many, first of all, we glossed over Almost Famous because you did that,
那个和《耶稣之子》。我之前对你说过，当我看到你和《耶稣之子》时，我就像，哦，天哪。但所以，太棒了，你一直都很棒，在很多事情上，多年来，你只是那种家伙，你也觉得我们总是支持它。就像你只是想让好事发生在你身上
you were so good in that and you just shot out of a cannon on that movie. Like it really took everybody, like it was awesome. So I- Are you listening, Jason? Yeah, no, I, it was- Okay, that was great. Let's just highlight what we'll say.
因为你是个很棒的家伙。但你和我之前多次谈论过的一件事，比利，不，这不是一个但是，这是除此之外的是，作为一个做过有史以来最伟大的配音活动之一的家伙，那就是-
That and Jesus is a son. I said that to you before, when I saw you and Jesus is a son, I was like, oh my God. But so, so good and you've been so good on, and so many things over, everything, over the years, and you were just one of those guys that also, you feel like we're always rooting for it. Like you just wanted good things to happen to you
真的是无价的，只是无价的工作。万事达卡当你去，去看电影，不管什么，5美元，得到回家的车- 等等，那是你？对，有一个你永远记得的夜晚，无价。无价。等等，那是你，比利。
because you're a great guy. But one of the things that you and I have talked about this before many times, Billy, no, it's not a but, it's in addition to that is, as you're a guy who did one of the great voiceover campaigns of all time, which was-
如果钱买不到一切，还有万事达卡，那是标语。没门，我不知道。那是正确的。那是他很长一段时间。那不是它发生的方式，威尔它像这样工作吗？对，让我们让那个人做，威尔。
Really a priceless, just priceless work. The Mastercard when you go, go into the movies, whatever, $5, getting a ride home- Wait, that was you? Yeah, having a night that you remember forever, priceless. Priceless. Wait, that was you, Billy.
对，我们走，我们走。继续，三，二，动作。麦克风，24.50美元，新电脑，1600美元。一小时的聪明，无价。有些东西是钱买不到的。对于其他一切，有万事达卡。万事达卡，万事达卡，万事达卡。那样，那太疯狂了。
If money can't buy for everything else, there's Mastercard, that's the tagline. No way, I didn't know that. That is correct. That was him for a long time. That's not exactly how it went, will it work like this? Yeah, let's let the guy do it, Will.
我不知道那是你，那太酷了。这是一个标志性的活动。威尔和我有一个共同点，因为他显然一直在做所有其他可用的配音。是的，一切，太多了。但比利，比利作为一个家伙，作为一个配音家伙在过去，当没有那么多人
Yeah, here we go, here we go. Go ahead, three, two, action. Microphone, $24.50, new computer, $1,600. One hour of smartless, priceless. There are some things money can't buy. For everything else, there's Mastercard. Mastercard, Mastercard, Mastercard. That way, that's crazy.
在那个时候做它，你做了很长时间。我忘了是多少年了。13年，对。13年。对，我记得它是多么独特。它是，你知道，当那个广告出现时，那个声音，它和我想象中之前所有的东西都不一样。
I didn't know that was you, that's so cool. There's an iconic campaign. Will and I had it in common, because he's been doing obviously every other voiceover that has been available. Yes, everything, it's too much. But Billy, Billy as a guy, as a voiceover guy back in the day, when there weren't as many people
绝对，它是一个游戏规则改变者。对，多么伟大的活动。我不知道它是关于什么的。你知道，有时候我们很幸运，正如我相信你们所有人知道的那样，特别是你，贾斯汀。很多运气。运气是职业生涯的重要组成部分。对。
doing it at the time, you did that for a long time. I forget how many years it was. 13 years, yeah. 13 years. Yeah, I remember how like it was very singular. It was, you know, when that commercial came on and that voice, and it was different than I think all the other stuff beforehand.
这就是为什么我们很棒。我在正确的时间出现在正确的地点。我实际上，我为这个制作的女人做了录音，你知道，她的广告代理显然在寻找合同。我们为冠军做了一个。我只是为了会议费做的。她说，我们要尝试为万事达卡做，
Absolutely, it was a game changer. Yeah, what a great campaign. I don't know what it was about. You know, sometimes we get lucky and stuff, as I think all of you guys know, especially you, Jason. Lot of luck. Luck is a big part of a career. Yeah.
250美元会议费。你为什么不进来做呢？然后她过了一会儿给我打电话。她说，我们赢得了活动，他们听了，他们说，你能只用你在那个里用的声音吗，我当时有点像，啊，好吧，我的意思是，我们要拍多少个？
That's why we're great. I was in the right place at the right time. I actually, I did session recording for this woman who produced, you know, her ad agency obviously was looking for a contract. We did one for champion. And I just did it for the session fee. She goes, we're gonna try to do it for MasterCard,
然后到了第三年，我像，我们能永远别停止吗？对。一旦你锁定了它。好吧，你知道它是什么吗？它是薪水的稳定性。所以即使是1万，只要知道你那年能得到1万，
$250 session fee. Why don't you come in and do it? And then she called me a little later. She said, we won the campaign and they listened and they said, can you just use the voice that you used in the, and I was kind of like, ah, all right, I mean, how many of these are we gonna do?
它有助于缓解年轻职业生涯中的许多紧张焦虑。但正如威尔所知，你开始变得足够好，你可以在20分钟内滚进去做10或15个。而且威尔，威尔从家里做。对。我的意思是，他已经从家里给他们打电话有一段时间了。
And then by the third year, I'm like, can we please never stop this? Yeah. Once you're locked into it. Well, you know what it is? It's the stability of the salary. So even if it's 10 grand, just knowing that you're gonna get 10 grand that year,
耶稣基督，船员。你知道吗？我告诉你这个，我确实在今年夏天对他说了，因为，你知道，约翰做，正如我们所知，他做梅赛德斯。他说，我甚至不做。约翰尼·哈姆。约翰尼·哈姆。
it helps with a lot of the nervous anxiety in a young career. But as Will well knows, you start to get good enough at it that you can roll in and do 10 or 15 of them in 20 minutes. And well, Will does it from home. Yeah. I mean, he's been phoning him from home for a while.
我说，你做那个多久了？他说，13年。我说，哦，那很可爱。你明白我的意思吗？那很可爱。他做了13年了吗？对。对，是的。
Jesus Christ, crewed up. You know what? I tell you this, I did say to him this summer we were talking because, you know, John does the, as we all know, he does the Mercedes. And he's like, I go, I don't even do. Johnny Ham. Johnny Ham.
什么？现在，你最长的是什么，威尔？我的意思是，你已经做GMC 60年了，对吧？GMC，我的意思是，今年将是25年。那不是真的。25年。这是一个真实的故事，对。那太神奇了。
I go, how long have you been doing that? And he goes, 13 years. And I go, oh, that's cute. You know what I mean? That's cute. Has he been doing it for 13 years? Yeah. Yeah, yes.
你在开玩笑吗？不，在今年年底，我将做吉姆的声音25年。那太不可思议了。世界上有更好的东西吗？我的意思是。不，它是最伟大的。但你知道吗？
What? Now, what's your longest one, Will? I mean, you've been doing GMC for 60 years, right? GMCs, I mean, this year it'll be 25 years. That's not true. 25 years. That's a true story, yeah. That's amazing.
知道你会很酷。每次那个里斯在想，我就像，哦，天哪，那是威尔。这是一件有趣的事情。但我会说在90年代，比利，当你做那个时，我提起它的原因，因为对我也一样，作为一个过着薪水到薪水生活的年轻演员
Are you kidding? No, at the end of this year it'll be 25 years I've been the voice of Jim. That's unbelievable. Is there a better thing in the world? I mean. No, it's the greatest. But you know what though?
当我得到配音工作时，这意味着我不必去干其他工作。我可以依靠那个。完全。所以你可以为其他一切试镜。因为如果你在其他地方找到工作，那么它会带走你，试镜总是很复杂。
It is cool knowing you will. And every time that Reese's thinking, I was like, oh my God, there's Will. It's a fun thing. But I will say that in the 90s, Billy, when you were doing that, and the reason I brought it up, because yeah, for me as well, as a young actor who was living paycheck to paycheck
而我所做的只是试镜，因为我没有得到很多角色。我多年来只得到试镜。我觉得你们谈论你们客户的方式很恶心，只是某种像，你知道，工作保障。你知道，当我谈论现代时，好吧，当我谈论现代时，
when I would get voiceover gigs, it meant that I didn't have to go and do other jobs. And I could rely on that. Exactly. So you could audition for everything else. Because if you got a job working somewhere else, then it would take you was always complicated trying to audition.
我这样做是因为它是一辆不可思议的车辆。好吧？耶稣。它是你世界上想要的一切。好吧？我不为钱做。我不为名声做。哦，他们听到了。
And all I did was audition, because I wasn't getting a lot of parts. I was only getting auditions for many years. I think it's disgusting the way you guys are talking about your clients is just some sort of this like, you know, job security. You know, when I talk about Hyundai, well, when I talk about Hyundai,
你不为钱做，哈？我知道。我享受钱。相信我。但我不为钱做。我这样做是因为我相信。我被纠正了。你是绝对正确的。
I'm doing it because it's an incredible vehicle. Okay? Jesus. It's everything you want in the world. Okay? I don't do it for money. I don't do it for the fame. Oh, they heard that.
现代，这是你的旅程，伙计们。耶稣。这是你的旅程。那是标签吗？我相信是。我相信是。男孩。真的，真的引起共鸣。
You don't do it for money, huh? I know. I enjoy the money. Believe me. But I don't do it for the money. I do it because I believe. I stand corrected. You are absolutely right.
所以，它很棒。好吧，听着，只有一家公司可以是专业级的。另一个可以提供旅程。哈？那是真的。那是真的。听着，伙计。我开奥迪。
Hyundai, it's your journey, guys. Jesus. It's your journey. Is that the tag? I believe it is. I believe it is. Boy. Really, really resonates.
哦，哔哔。我们可以说。我们可以说。那是贾斯汀的标签。我只是去哔哔，哔哔。肖恩，你应该说，我开奥迪穿过我车道尽头的门，因为你有。我开奥迪，但我没有。
So, it's great. Well, listen, only one company can be professional grade. The other one can supply a journey. Huh? That's true. That's true. Listen, man. I drive an Audi.
好吧，所以。所以，无论如何。我给了一个活动。比利。天哪，比利，你只是做了一切。现在是一个完整的圆圈。现在，你和梭罗已经做了很长时间的朋友了。真实的故事。
Oh, beep, beep. We can tell. We can tell. That's the tag with Jason. I just go beep, beep. Sean, you should have said, I drive an Audi through my gate at the end of my driveway because you have. I drive an Audi, but I haven't any.
对，我们做了一个非常，非常困倦的《三姐妹》制作，那个。哦，你做了？安东·契诃夫的。对，当然。在圆环剧院公司。哦。我们有艾米·欧文，吉恩·特里普霍恩，
All right, so. So, anyway. I gave it a campaign. Billy. God, Billy, you've just done it all. Now it's a full circle. And now, you and Thoreau have been friends for a long time. True story.
和莉莉·泰勒作为姐妹。大卫·斯特雷泽恩怎么样。地狱般的演员阵容。喜欢那个，吉恩·特里普霍恩。杰瑞·斯蒂勒在那部作品里。没门。对，还有吉亚马蒂。多么，而且我喜欢吉亚马蒂。
Yeah, we did a very, very sleepy production of The Three Sisters, the. Oh, you did? By Anton Chekhov. Yeah, of course. At the Roundabout Theater Company. Oh. We had Amy Irving, Gene Triplehorn,
吉亚马蒂是什么堵塞活动。我的意思是，我不认识他，但多么伟大的演员。他太棒了。你从那时起就和梭罗很亲近了。你怎么样？从那时起，然后当我们住在华盛顿广场公园时，我们住在隔壁。
and Lily Taylor as the sisters. How David Stratharen. Hell of a cast. Love that, Gene Triplehorn. Jerry Stiller was in that production. No way. Yeah, and Giamatti. What a, and I love Giamatti.
他离我两个门。所以我们过去，在那些我们抽烟的日子里。告诉我这是不是真的。我听说你不得不搬家，因为他叫来的狗仔队。他叫来去，因为他会叫并去，
Giamatti is what a jammed activities. I mean, I don't know him, but what a great actor. He's fantastic. You've been close with Thoreau since then. How are you doing? Since then, and then we lived next door to each other when we were on Washington Square Park.
吉亚玛提真是个……我是说，我不认识他，但他真是位伟大的演员。他太棒了。从那以后你和索罗一直很亲近吗？你们最近怎么样？从那以后，我们住在华盛顿广场公园旁边时还是邻居。
He was two doors down from me. And so we used to, back in the days when we smoked cigarettes. Tell me if this is true. And I heard that you had to move because of the paparazzi that he was calling. That he was calling to come, cause he would call and go,
他住在我家隔两个门的地方。所以我们过去常常，在那个我们还抽烟的年代。告诉我这是不是真的。我听说你不得不搬家是因为他招来的狗仔队。他打电话叫他们来，因为他会打电话说，
hey, I'm home guys. I'm about to go out, right? Is that true? Can you picture me? That is true. And then they would see me in my tank top. They'd start taking pictures. I'd get on, I'd put on my messenger bag.
嘿，我到家了，伙计们。我正要出门，对吧？是真的吗？你能想象我吗？那是真的。然后他们会看到我穿着背心。他们会开始拍照。我会上车，背上我的邮差包。
I'd get on my. I'd say 10 feet. Just a stunt double again. I'll be stepping out in three, two, one. Can't you compare? If you can get me as soon as I get on the bike, as my leg is going over the bike. There it was.
我会上我的。我会说10英尺。又是一个替身。我将在三、二、一后走出去。你不能比较吗？如果你能在我上自行车时拍到我，就在我的腿跨过自行车的时候。就在那儿。
That's why I moved. That's why you moved. God, remember how quickly Thoreau gave up smoking? He was really quick on it, wasn't he? Wait, what? I don't remember that. Yeah, he quit smoking. He just dropped.
这就是我搬家的原因。这就是你搬家的原因。天哪，还记得梭罗戒烟有多快吗？他戒得真快，不是吗？等等，什么？我不记得了。是的，他戒烟了。他只是突然就不抽了。
Well, I put them down. Like two thousand eight, I want to say. And then he just like one day he was done. We have a friend that did hypnosis and that worked. No more smoking. Yeah, the hypnosis has worked for a friend of mine too. Yeah. I just stopped.
嗯，我把它们放下了。我想大概是2008年吧。然后他就像有一天突然就戒了。我们有个朋友做了催眠，那很有效。不再抽烟了。是的，催眠对我的一位朋友也有效。是的。我只是停下来了。
But I mean, Justin is putting a curtain on the Nicarad industry. He never stopped. He and another good friend of ours never stopped chewing the gum and they are fucking crazy. Yeah, they just dropped those little turds all over the place.
但我的意思是，贾斯汀正在给尼古丁行业挂上窗帘。他从来没有停止过。他和我们的另一个好朋友从来没有停止过嚼口香糖，他们简直疯了。是的，他们只是到处乱扔那些小粪便。
They give me anxiety and sort of, I don't know. She just stuck with the cigarettes well. Right, I think go back to the smokes. I'm not a doctor. Listen to this. I'm not a, I'm glad you said, I say it all the time. I'm not because that I'm not a doctor. But I will say, I tried to do one of those,
它们让我焦虑，而且，我不知道。她只是很好地坚持抽烟。对，我想回到抽烟的状态。我不是医生。听着。我不是，我很高兴你这么说，我一直这么说。我不是，因为我不是医生。但我会说，我试过做其中一种，
the vape pen, you know, the vape thing for a little, for a minute, that gave me anxiety too. Maybe I feel like shit. Thoreau, by the way, let's be honest. Thoreau likes to get into the little jewelry type things too. Okay. Wow, he's chewing the gum.
电子烟，你知道，那个电子烟，有一会儿，有一分钟，那也让我感到焦虑。也许我感觉糟透了。顺便说一句，说实话，梭罗也喜欢搞那些小首饰之类的东西。好吧。哇，他在嚼口香糖。
He's got one of those. He's taken a lot of fire. Yeah, I know he's taken one on his. Well, we haven't loved any grenades his way in a while. So it's about time that he took some, we've laughed about 25 today. Wake up, JT. All right, this is enough.
他有其中一个。他承受了很多炮火。是的，我知道他在他的身上承受了一个。好吧，我们已经有一段时间没有向他投掷任何手榴弹了。所以他承受一些是时候了，我们今天已经笑了大约25次了。醒醒，JT。好吧，这足够了。
We've taken up enough of your time. You probably got to do a re-record on a hypochondriac, or probably maybe, you know, do some pickups on that. A couple pickups. I think we got everything we needed on that. You guys can let us know. If I'm the gang over at MasterCard,
我们已经占用了你足够多的时间了。你可能需要对疑病症进行重新录制，或者可能，你知道，做一些补录。几个补录。我想我们已经得到了我们需要的一切。你们可以告诉我们。如果我是万事达卡的那帮人，
I'm thinking like, I'm hearing this, I'm going, and I'm a new young executive. He's still got it. He's got a history and he's still fucking got it. And everybody, they love reboots and remakes. I'd be like, let's get Kudup in here. Fuck it. It's a great point in her net.
我在想，我听到了这个，我在想，我是一个年轻的新高管。他依然宝刀未老。他有历史，而且他依然该死地宝刀未老。每个人，他们都喜欢重启和翻拍。我会说，让库达普来这里。去他的。这是一个很好的观点。
Oh my God. And why haven't Aline and Jimmy thought about that? I don't know. Maybe just the MasterCard folks just need your number. Give him your cell phone real quick. Yeah, let's get the, let's get the cell phone. 917. It's 800.
天哪。为什么艾琳和吉米没有想到这一点？我不知道。也许万事达卡的人只是需要你的号码。快给他你的手机号码。是的，让我们拿到手机号码。917。是800。
Yep. Wow, he's still on the 800. Oh God. Sounds. I missed a couple. Yeah. Well, listen, William. Guys, it's been a pleasure.
是的。哇，他还在用800。天哪。声音。我错过了几个。是的，好吧，听着，威廉。伙计们，这真是太荣幸了。
It's been such a pleasure. It's been mine. No, mine. I've enjoyed this more than anyone. We all see each other for dinner from time to time. And this is nice to just kind of see each other on this. I know. Let's go.
这真是太荣幸了。是我的荣幸。不，是我的。我比任何人都享受这次谈话。我们时不时会见面吃晚饭。能在这里见到彼此真是太好了。我知道。走吧。
Let's do, let's go. The four of us out to dinner one night. It's a safe space. Right. Come on, Jason. You do that. Let's go. Billy, what a delight.
让我们做吧，走吧。我们四个人有一天出去吃晚饭。这是一个安全的空间。对。来吧，杰森。你这样做。走吧。比利，真是太高兴了。
Listen, having you on the program here today and let me know about next week. Guys, this just started, right? The smart list thing. How long has it been going on? Great rehearsal. Let's go ahead and roll, guys. Rob, Bennett.
听着，今天让你参加这个节目，让我知道下周的情况。伙计们，这刚开始，对吧？SmartLess这个东西。已经持续多久了？很棒的排练。我们继续吧，伙计们。罗伯，贝内特。
I mean, what episode, what episode am I? Am I top 10? I mean, am I like chronologically? Well, we're gonna cut it together and we'll see if it's really airing. And how many of these have you done? Probably. 150.
我的意思是，我是哪一集？我是前10名吗？我的意思是，我是按时间顺序排列的吗？好吧，我们会把它剪辑在一起，看看它是否真的会播出。你做了多少集了？大概。150集。
Bennett, how many episodes are we doing? Yeah, we're like 137. 137. 137. 137. 140, 140. I've been around. Is there a number you would like to be as a long time deal?
贝内特，我们正在做多少集？是的，我们大概做了137集。137。137。137。140，140。我一直在。有一个你想要作为长期交易的数字吗？
You were busy memorizing dialogue and we didn't want to interrupt. So let me think about that dinner. Oh, fuck, this just took a turn. I'll see what kind of texts I get from Barnett over the next 24 hours to see if we can make this shit happen. Billy, we love you.
你当时忙着背台词，我们不想打断你。所以让我考虑一下那顿晚餐。哦，去他的，这事儿突然变了。我会看看接下来24小时内从巴内特那里收到什么样的短信，看看我们是否能让这事儿成真。比利，我们爱你。
Billy, we love you. We do love you. I miss you. Love you guys. Stop working so hard. Promoting Hello Tomorrow. Hello Tomorrow. Hello Tomorrow.
比利，我们爱你。我们确实爱你。我想你。爱你们，伙计们。别工作得太辛苦了。宣传《你好，明天》。《你好，明天》。《你好，明天》。
Hello Tomorrow. Exclamation point. Mastercard. You'll love Hello Tomorrow. Watching Hello Tomorrow with your friends? Priceless. There you go. There are some things money can't buy for everything else.
《你好，明天》。感叹号。万事达卡。你会喜欢《你好，明天》的。和朋友一起看《你好，明天》？无价。就是这样。有些东西是金钱买不到的，对于其他一切，有万事达卡。
I can't wait, Billy. That sounds like everything I'm for that show. I can't wait. Excellent. I hope you enjoy. There's some sci-fi in it. You'll like that part. That's why I'm gonna tune in.
我等不及了，比利。听起来那部剧就是我想要的。我等不及了。太棒了。希望你喜欢。里面有一些科幻元素。你会喜欢那部分的。这就是我为什么要收看的原因。
Yes. All right. Love you guys. Love you guys. Me and it. Bye, Billy. Love you guys. Bye, buddy.
是的。好吧。爱你们，伙计们。爱你们，伙计们。我和它。再见，比利。爱你们，伙计们。再见，伙计。
Bye. Oh, bye. Jay, when did you ask him to be on? Like, Billy's so great. I mean, I can't remember when. If I'm Billy, I'm mad at you. You know what I mean? Oh, really?
再见。哦，再见。杰伊，你什么时候邀请他来的？比利太棒了。我的意思是，我不记得是什么时候了。如果我是比利，我会生你的气。你知道我的意思吗？哦，真的吗？
Like, Krasinski mad? Hey. You know? That was inexcusable. What part? What are you talking about? Well, it will took 136 episodes before he invited John Krasinski on the show.
就像克拉辛斯基那样生气？嘿。你知道吗？那是不可原谅的。哪部分？你在说什么？好吧，花了136集才邀请约翰·克拉辛斯基上节目。
Oh, I know. Like, were not friends with him or something. God. I know. Fuck off. No, that Billy crewed up. I kept trying to figure out a joke to turn the last name into Crudite somehow crude up.
哦，我知道。就像我们和他不是朋友什么的。天哪。我知道。滚开。不，那是比利搞砸了。我一直试图想出一个笑话，把姓氏变成Crudite，不知怎么地搞砸了。
Or cut up. Like, he's a real cut up. Yeah. Boy, I'm glad you didn't. Yeah, just don't have it. Yeah, it would have been a real side slapper. Oh, man. Is that what it is?
或者cut up。就像他是个真正的开心果。是的。天哪，我很高兴你没这么做。是的，只是没有那个意思。是的，那会是一个真正的膝盖拍打者。哦，伙计。是那样吗？
No, knee slapper. But one of those actors that you see. You know, one of the sort of things about being a wordsmith is you have to know words. Oh. You know what I mean? Yeah. Yes.
不，是膝盖拍打者。但作为你看到的那些演员之一。你知道，作为一名文字工作者，你需要了解词汇。哦。你知道我的意思吗？是的。是的。
So. But Billy's one of those actors that's been in like a million things and he holds never not work. And they've all been great. And he's never sucked. And never. Never sucked.
所以。但比利是那种演过一百万部作品的演员，他从不失业。而且它们都很棒。他从来没有演砸过。从来没有。从来没有演砸过。
He's the kind of thing. Well, like if you see his name in a cast, you're like, oh, this is a high quality project. That's exactly right. Yeah. He's so good and he's so sweet and he's so handsome. And he's just got it all. He's handsome.
他是那种。嗯，就像如果你在演员表中看到他的名字，你会想，哦，这是一个高质量的项目。完全正确。是的。他太棒了，他太甜了，他太帅了。他拥有一切。他很帅。
Hey, hey, hey. He's really handsome, man. Sorry. I think you could take a shower or something. Sorry. You know what though? I can't wait to see his new show, Hello Tomorrow. I wonder what the sequel would be.
嘿，嘿，嘿。他真的很帅，伙计。抱歉。我想你可以去洗个澡什么的。抱歉。你知道吗？我迫不及待想看他的新剧《你好，明天》。我想知道续集会是什么。
It's Hello Tomorrow. And then maybe. Would it be? Bye. Don't go up high. Don't go up high. And then don't repeat it three times. Bye.
是《你好，明天》。然后也许。会是什么？再见。别往高处走。别往高处走。然后不要重复三次。再见。
Bye, tomorrow. Bye. Bye, tomorrow. Bye. Bye, tomorrow. Hello, tomorrow. Smart. Less.
再见，明天。再见。再见，明天。再见。再见，明天。《你好，明天》。SmartLess。
Smart. Less. Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Amjarf. Smart. Less.
SmartLess。Less。SmartLess是由贝内特·巴尔巴科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗伯·安贾夫手工制作的100%有机艺术品。SmartLess。
Our next episode will be out in a week, wherever you listen to podcasts. Or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music. Or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app. Hey, I'm Mike Corey, the host of Wondery's podcast Against the Odds.
我们的下一集将在下周发布，无论你在哪里收听播客。或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听。或者通过订阅Apple Podcasts或Wondery应用程序中的Wondery Plus来提前收听且无广告。嘿，我是迈克·科里，Wondery播客《逆境求生》的主持人。
Each week, we share thrilling true stories of survival and put you in the shoes of the heroes who live to tell the tale. In our next season, we take you to a remote corner of Alaska that's home to one of the densest brown bear populations in the world. But in recent years, the change in climate has caused a shortage of the bear's natural food sources.
每周，我们都会分享惊心动魄的真实生存故事，让你身临其境地感受那些幸存下来的英雄们的故事。在下一季中，我们将带你前往阿拉斯加的一个偏远角落，那里是世界上棕熊密度最高的地区之一。但近年来，气候变化导致棕熊的天然食物来源短缺。
More and more bears are venturing into the town of Haines, Alaska, in search of food, putting residents on edge. Then everyone's worst fears are realized. Three experienced back country skiers unknowingly ski over a den and awaken a mother bear and her cub. She attacks, and one of the men is left fighting for his life while his friends desperately wait for help to arrive.
越来越多的熊为了寻找食物冒险进入阿拉斯加的海恩斯镇，让居民们感到不安。然后，每个人最担心的恐惧变成了现实。三名经验丰富的野外滑雪者在不知情的情况下滑过一个洞穴，惊醒了一只母熊和它的幼崽。它发起了攻击，其中一名男子在生死边缘挣扎，而他的朋友们则绝望地等待救援。
Follow Against the Odds wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen ad-free on the Amazon Music or Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在任何你获取播客的地方关注《逆境求生》。你可以在亚马逊音乐或Wondery应用程序上收听无广告版。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。